hello and welcome to this evening's
meeting of planning and development
management committee
and just by way of introduction my name
is adrian williams and i serve as the
chair of the committee
i'm also president on the committee vice
chair councillor ben hartley
offices from the council's planning
service legal and democratic service
local highway authority as well as
elected councillors who make up the
voting members of the committee
and before we continue i should just
advise everyone's attention
this meeting has been live streamed and
recorded so please mute your microphones
to minimize background noise
if you wish to speak on an item please
use the chat facility to notify me
and then wait until you're invited to
speak
um just turn into the agenda noting
attendances
that we have received apologies from
councillor procter
and councillor acton is serving as a
substitute member of the committee
this evening thank you council um
item two are there any declarations of
interest
from any members yes chair
um i've i have an interest in the
application
in relation to trafford magistrates
court site so
i'm intending to speak against that
application as ward councillor so
i won't um sit on the committee for that
application
uh council accordingly
it's the opposite actually i'm
discharging an interest
london circle court when that came
in last time i did declare
i was acting as ward counsel and
i need to make clear tonight i consider
as a new
application and i'm not declaring i'm
not going to step
out of this one it's be complicated but
i
i thought it was well to declare that
thank you councillor um i should myself
declare that um on
stratfor public hall i live really quite
close to this site
and additionally think that i may have
had some interaction
um with one of the objectives through my
uh day job
as consequence i won't be participating
on that item
i can't see anybody else indicating that
they wish to register an interest oh
council minutes
sorry yes i wish to
declare an interest with um the
application at willow's primary school
my uh younger son
still attends that school um elder one
is at wellington thank you
thank you councillor and moving on
agenda item three
is minutes which have been circulated to
members
anyone happy to move in second those as
an accurate representation
paper to move chair they're accurate
thank you
[Music]
thank you council of the councillor
hunting and we'll take them
as approved then um questions
from members of the public um just to
confirm the committee that
we did receive one question uh from a
member of the public prior to this
meeting however it was assessed by
the officers as not being within the
scope of the committee to respond to
and that member of the public has been
contacted by the council's planning
department
separately to discuss that um
item five there has been an additional
information report circulated
via email to members that people managed
to
reflect on that and moving now on to
uh item number six which is uh
applications for permission to develop
and the first application that we're
going to consider this evening
is former magistrates court in sale
which is on page 116
of the committee report before we move
further the item is going to be
introduced by mr pearson
thank you thank you gentlemen i'll just
try and share my screen with you now for
the presentation
can i just has that um how's that
appeared on the screen
yeah it has thank you thank you okay um
thank you for that okay this um this
site comprises the former trafford
magistrates court
um you can see the location plan there
um two separate parcels of land the
the main magistrates court site uh here
and then the land known as the gyratory
system
uh just to to the rest of it here
the application proposes um
38 apartments in in two blocks along
cross street here one one
block here and one block here and then
46 dwellings
along ashton lane here uh york road here
and brighton grove there um
they comprise a mix of terrorists and
semi-detached houses
21 of those units will be delivered as
affordable homes
with 13 apartments for affordable rent
and eight houses for shared ownership
the proposals also include a pocket park
here and private amenity spaces for the
apartments here and here in addition to
the planting of street trees
on cross street and
the lane development seeks to reinstate
a traditional
terrorist street layout onto the site
including the reinstatements of the new
street known as whittle street
which is sat between these two blocks
here
um the proposal is considered to be well
designed scheme comprising high quality
buildings and public realm
that we think would establish a strong
sense of place
and be a positive addition to the sport
for sale
all the existing trees on the site with
one exception
uh this this tree here that sits between
the two apartment blocks would be
removed
and that is understandably considered to
be an adverse impact
scheme which has to be weighed in the
planning balance
however a total of 111 new trees
are to be planted including 25 street
trees to
cross street ashton lane and brighton
grove
because of the removal of the existing
trees and the impact on habitat or
contribution towards offsite
habitat enhancement works is also
proposed
the proposal includes the removal of the
generator
um on this slide i appreciate it's
the text probably isn't very large but
this site slide
seeks to demonstrate how the
existing traffic flow works on the left
so these are the
sort of orange arrows um
and you you basically have sort of
one-way traffic
coming up cranley drive where you can
either turn left
downstairs just from ashton village or
right towards the a50 fixed
brighton grove is is you can have you
can only access that from the a56 you go
in and come out the same way
york road operates as a one-way road
coming down in
in this direction uh where you can
either join the a56 or or go right
and head to washington village traffic
coming from ashton village
to get to the a56 needs to go around
this
uh around the gyratory and come down
here
so because the generatory is proposed to
uh as part of the development site that
that requires
a change to to the road system
um and what and what happens is that we
get new giveaway junctions being created
um with a junction of york road and
cranley drive with
with ashland ashton lane
york road would be made two-way between
the ashton lane junction
up to palace road which is just here the
entry to the
fiona gardens and the section of ashton
lane
south of the gyro h3 between park road
and york road
would also be modified to a two-way
carriageway
this roadway is considered to be
acceptable
um by the by the lha
let's move on to the next slide we've
got a few
visuals here that one
is taken from the crossroads of ashton
lane the a56 and school road at
the heart of the entry to um
to the town centre um
and you can see here the three-story
apartment block
and then the four-story or the three
story with the the kind of
setback fourth story further down
towards
towards stratford um this particular
block has been
its height has we've tried to keep that
down too
so it sits comfortably comfortably with
the existing buildings
at the junction and there's also been a
chamfered corner introduced which is
also a detail reflected on some of the
other buildings
on on the corner at the junction the
detailing of these buildings includes
deep window reveals to give the building
some depth
and character and natural stone
surrounds to the windows
on on the corner
the view down there is ashton lane
next one we've got views here of the
proposed development on
brighton grove so you can see that these
units present themselves as two-story
with
integral garages you can see here the
back of
apartment block a2
on the a56 this view here
is a russian lane and that's looking
towards the ae 56 so that's the back of
apartment block a1 and you can see the
the reinstatement of of properties
close to the back of footpath on on
ashton lane
with brick boundary walls to certify
some private space
this shot down here is the internal
street within the main body of the site
sort of known as whittle street there
was a street called little street
within that part of the site many years
ago um
so it seems to recreate that and these
terrorist units
are three stories in height with a flat
roof very contemporary appearance they
include
an integral garage as well
and then finally we've got a sort of
aerial shot
of the site here so this illustrates
quite well the
retention um of the london plane tree
uh between sat between the two apartment
buildings we
sense that this will give create a real
sense of place
and it also creates a route through to
um to york road um or even to ashton
lane if you if you want to avoid uh the
busier astronomer
so that's the um those are the images of
the
of the development home i'll leave those
um
on the screen while i uh i just finish
off the presentation
um 33 objections have been received
to the scheme the main issues raised
relating to the loss of the area of
green space
formed by the j racery highway safety
issues
additional traffic and problems on
surrounding roads
as a result of the amended road layout
and insufficient car parking
by there have been no objections in
principle from the council's fees
subject to appropriate conditions
officers think that the proposals
provide an acceptable level of car
parking for future arguments
taking into account this is a highly
sustainable location
well served by public transport and
close to town center facilities
existing parking restrictions on most
surrounding roads
will prevent any over spill parking from
the development
during the restricted periods but a
traffic regulation order review
is recommended of that residents only
parking scheme
to look at the potential for extending
that
for those to protect existing residents
and make sure there isn't any adverse
impact on them
so the thinking being that whilst uh
non-residents can park on those roads
later in the evening overnight if the
tro
were to be introduced then those uh
restrictions could be introduced
uh until late at night to effectively
present
prevent new residents bargaining on
existing roads
the highway authorities have also
indicated that the traffic of
associated with development will have an
adverse impact local highway network
um in addition to the 25 affordable
housing offer
contributions in respect of open space
and sports facilities are also proposed
and as all schools in the area are at
capacity a
full contribution towards the creation
of both
new primary and secondary school places
is proposed but this is based on the
pupil yield generated by the development
and applying the dfe school places
scorecard rates as recommended by the df
this has been calculated as twenty 220
three hundred and eighteen pounds
towards primary schools
and two hundred and eighteen thousand
seven hundred and twenty pounds
towards secondary school resulting in a
total contribution of
439 038 pounds
and it's worth noting that that
calculation
represents a new uplifted figure based
on the new dfe rates
compared to that which would have been
sought um as recently a couple of months
ago
the benefits of the scheme are
considered to include the provision of
84 new
dwellings which will obviously
contribute towards the council's
identified housing land
supply shortfall in a sustainable
location
and on predominantly brownfield land
again with 25
of the units being affordable proposals
therefore considered to be in accordance
with
core strategy policy and the national
planning policy framework
therefore recommended that planning
permissions should be granted
i would just like to draw members
attention to the additional information
report
um there are a number of points on that
which i think it's worth highlighting
um if you can just play with me and i'll
i'll i'll talk you through
through that um so the first
page for this application starts
on page six of your edition information
report
um it has come to light that there's a
very small path
of unregistered land uh which kind of
sits between the gyratory and the
existing apartment block that faces it
so as a result of that we
the applicant has had to serve a new
certificate to a company revised
application
form and that's been advertised in the
evening news
to see whether or not anybody else
who might have an interest in that band
wants to make any
representations um so that's on
on page six um also on page six
and then moving on to page seven we've
got um
some additional consultation responses
and one additional
representation received um from the
business located on
the road shops on cross street adjacent
to brighton grove
there are a number of highway shoes
um uh reported on
between pages seven eight really in
response to some of the concerns
expressed by
by the objectors um
to say those are seven eight nine so
i'll
skip through those um obviously happy to
answer any questions on those
uh later or during the debate
um we've got a number of other issues
crime prevention
uh security slight updates there slight
update on the biodiversity point
and then an important update in terms of
the developer contributions
so on paragraph this refers to paragraph
204
of the main reports and it had initially
been intended that the contributions
would be
made through a voluntary allocation
either came
into the section 106 but should planning
permission be granted
uh on first occupation of properties
however further legal advice in the form
of council advice has been taken on this
point
and it's now proposed that those
contributions will be secured by a
grampy condition
that development can't commence until an
agreement has been entered
into with the local planning authority
to pay the contributions
further granting conditions proposed
that in the event that the land is sold
before the
development a section 106 agreement is
entered into by the new owner
to cat with a with a council to pay the
contributions
and this will ensure that the obligation
to pay the contributions
will run with the land and these two
conditions will allow the planning
authority
to have full confidence contributions
can be fully
and lawfully secured
as a result of the um unregistered land
point
um there is a change to the wording of
the recommendation
that just come down there towards the
bottom of page 11.
um and because because that advert is
running
uh in the evening news until the 26th
march the recommendation is to grant
subject to no
further representations being received
before the 26th of march
raised material considerations not
previously
included or addressed in office report
or the additional information report
and of course subject to the conditions
which were in the main report
and finally the last part of the
additional information report
does include some amendments to existing
conditions
um as you can see there on pages 11 and
12.
and then there are some additional
conditions uh and the first two there
36 and 37 cover the points i just raised
in relation to this point about the
class being the
applicant and the need to secure an
appropriate way of
of securing the contributions
um and that concludes the introduction
sorry that was fairly lengthy but i
thought it was important to go through
those
i'll i'll take the um i'll take the
presentation
thank you uh mr pearson um the three
people uh speaking against the
application
council is hartley and holden and a
statement from
mr wilson to be read out there's been
any discussion as to who'd like to
speak first you know
mr chairman sorry yeah i've just
realized that culture council holds
night story council
yes okay thank you
there's there's not been a discussion
chair between uh
council allah myself i'm afraid i think
this the resident
uh is having a statement read out um i
i'm completely easy i'm happy to go
after council alarm and and
pick up any points that um that he
doesn't mention
if we can read out the statement first
then and then council alum and council
hartley that's great thank you
okay um statement regarding planning
application
1-0-2-8-2-2 i am colin wilson
and i have lived on york avenue since
1985. though i am broadly in favor of
the redevelopment of the law court
site i am extremely concerned that the
construction traffic
will use york road to access the site
sorry we'll use york avenue to access
the site on york road
and possibly park in the one-hour bays
while queueing for the site
i am worried that once the development
is populated
york avenue will see an increase in
traffic
accessing the new properties any
construction and other traffic
on the a56 coming from manchester from
the manchester direction
will get to the development site will
almost certainly want to turn right onto
park avenue
then left into york avenue to access the
site on york road
this is because there's no right turn
off the a56 after park avenue
until well past the site both park
avenue and york avenue are completely
unsuitable
for hdb vehicles as york arrow is now
york avenue is narrow and access from
park avenue is very tight
left turn with less than two meters
radius access on the corner
permissive parking on park and york
avenue
also reduces the width of the roads to a
point that vehicles cannot pass
each other i strongly suggest that an
alternative route should be found
this problem has not been addressed all
in any of the traffic analysis for this
device
element i would strongly advise that
these avenues are considered in the
construction traffic management plan
described
on page 190 section 31 of the planning
application
i believe it should also be considered
in the residential traffic survey as
detailed on page 186
section 17 of the planning application
to monitor any increase in traffic
levels from the completed development
interestingly the demolition company did
recognize this problem
and diverted all site vehicles to avoid
park and york avenues
and this worked very well i am concerned
that failure to consider this point will
cause additional traffic congestion on
these avenues
as well as excessive noise and vibration
and damage to the road surface
thank you
thank you um councillor hartley
the council alum sorry
thank you very much um well thank you
for
allowing me the opportunity to address
the committee on this particular
application and just to point out that
i also speak on behalf of councillor
rigby my ward
colleague and i'm obviously delighted
that councillor ben hartley is also
going to
speak on this on uh the first thing i
wish to make clear is that
development of the former magistrates
court site is welcome
particularly as this provides much
needed homes in the area as mr pearson
was was pointing out however both
councillor rigby and i have expressed
concerns
about the real pressures that this
scheme and several others that are
proposed in the immediate area
brings for school places in
sale so the contribution that mr pearson
has highlighted is welcome but outside
of this application
we believe a more thorough far-reaching
approach is needed but except that
obviously that's not a particular point
for her
discussion uh this evening residents
quite rightly have raised concerns about
the inadequate number of car parking
spaces
across the proposed scheme which we
totally support
and there are of course concerns about
traffic flow movements in the proposed
reconfigured junction of york road and
ashton lane
having said that mr chairman in the time
that i have i want to focus
on that aspect of the application that
proposes to extend the
magistrates court uh site
uh into the existing gyratory which we
saw very clearly on the
uh in in the short presentation this
aspect has attracted
a considerable number of objections and
in our view
with uh really good reasons
it does seem quite incredible that it's
the council of all applicants
that is proposing to build on a piece of
open green space
it's an open green space situated in a
very built up part of sail
town center and clearly provides a
welcoming gateway into the shopping and
commercial center
for sale for local pedestrians from in
and around
the residential area of ascendant mersey
the immunity loss would be in our view
considerable
and once gone would never be recovered
so it might be easy to dismiss this
green space as a nearly over large
roundabout
indeed traffic does flow around its
edges
but as the report points out it does
have some quite
special features it as probably
it has properly designed and designated
pedestrian routes
and is host to a number of mature trees
mr chairman members of the committee i
would suggest to you that the gyratory
was designed to be enjoyed by residents
and has a utility
beyond simply controlling traffic which
incidentally
it does extremely well it is really
not stretching the point to say that the
gyratory
is a green oasis in a densely built up
area the trees afford a habitat for
birds
which can be rare in a town centre
the proposed pocky park is no
compensation
for the loss of this green space and
mature trees
it's not called a pocket park for
nothing mr chairman
it means it's small as in pocket size
small
the tree loss for the whole scheme is
actually quite shocking especially as
some of the trees
albeit on the former magistrates court
site
have the potential to in the words of
our own tree experts
become some of the most attractive trees
in sale
on the gyratory nine trees mainly
weeping ashes
face the axe and we they might
as will residents if you allow this
silver vandalism
to proceed as one objector points out
this is the only significant green space
in the vicinity of sail town centre and
this heavily populated area
it provides the only green space for
residents of
the trident apartments in ashton lane
cranley drive
and the park court flats and other local
properties
the report talks about the ownership
legalities
relating to the gyratory and that at the
end of the day
the council can build on it but
residents don't see it that way
it's considered to be a public space
because of the many many years
it's been available to them and used by
them
to summarize mr chairman the gyratory
should be left alone
so that it continues to provide a
visually pleasing aspect
to this key part of sale it's an amenity
which surely must be left for future
generations to enjoy
including the future residents the time
visage would live on the
magistrates court site itself
i would therefore urge that members of
the committee
refuse this application in its present
form
in order to protect and preserve the
very important open space
which is valued by so many residents
thank you very much mr chairman thank
you councillor lam
um councillor hartley
thank you chair i'm gonna share council
alums sort of
closing sentiments that uh very happy
with the proposal to develop housing on
this site
i just think the application could be
much better and i think there are some
additional adverse impacts
to this application that are not fully
considered in the report so that's what
i'll
focus my um remarks on i'm concerned
about the
level of community involvement in the in
the application
there are a number of residents on park
road york road howells avenue that
didn't receive the leaflet about the
proposals
there are also some uh valid queries
valid suggestions raised by residents to
make the scheme more acceptable
and and none of those have been taken on
board there's no significant change to
the application
um during during that consultation
process that i can see
cancer lambs talked about the loss of
green space quite extensively
i would agree with him on that very
little green space in ashland or mersey
on that
in that part of sale the council should
be protecting
uh existing open space and improving the
quality of open space
even though that land is not does not
have any protected
status and there's a real missed
opportunity i think because
that area could be could be improved the
road
that loops behind the generator it could
be closed off
and then it will become a much more
usable pocket park effectively but much
better than the one that's proposed
right next to the a56 which you know for
that reason i can't believe any
resident would want to sit in or if they
do they'll probably sit there only once
um my second area of concern that i've
got is
changed to the road layout i think that
um that will have an impact on on
queuing
traffic um to be clear this the the
entry of cars to
oakland's drive and then cranley um
cranley drive is
is controlled by traffic lights so the
traffic doesn't arrive in a uniform
fashion it arrives in bunches but at the
moment it's
pretty free-flowing but with the head of
cranley drive
being changed so that traffic needs to
give way and the road being narrowed
from
two lanes to one that is bound to cause
long queues of traffic
in my view and that will have an impact
on the residence on cranley drive
a third area of objection i have is a
failure to deliver quality walking and
cycling infrastructure
this is a missed opportunity but it's
also a planning requirement
paragraph 108 of the mppf and a core
strategy
l 4.4 says that developments are
required
to provide and promote pedestrian
cyclists movements as a priority
and to demonstrate how their development
will contribute towards
connections and deliver quality cycling
on walking
walking infrastructure the lha
identified a problem of the lack of
pedestrian crossings and the designer's
response to that is
drop curves and tactile paving that's
not sufficient
given the junctions being radically
remodeled zebra crossings should be
built in to give pedestrians priority
across ashton lane and cranley drive or
york road
turning to cycling the a56 and the
bridgewater way are not safe cycling
routes
the a56 temporary cycle lane
when it came through that part of sale
did cause problems i think everyone is
aware of that
again there's another real opportunity
here so i've contacted the highways team
before
to suggest an alternative cycle route
which doesn't depart much from the a56
direct route so a second you could have
a segregated cycle then that heads north
along cranley drive
york road york avenue bring your road to
park avenue and from there it's only a
short distance to
cleveland's road where cycle lane
provision is planned
and at least some of that route is
related to this development
and in my view is is more imperative
because of the reduced
parking issue fourth area of concern i
have is road safety the transport
assessment says there's no reasons to
assume this situation should be
significantly worsened as a consequence
of the development proposals
there's no analysis of the impact of the
changes to junction on road safety
and that's not sufficient um the
transport assessment says that
there's only been one accident at that
junction in the last 21 years
as one of the residents objections
points out that's
a an accident rate of 0.05
per year and she's referred to formula
which
indicate the junction changes will
result in 0.97 accidents a year which is
a significant increase
that that term may not be right but to
give that no analysis is not sufficient
final area of concern i have is parking
there's a shortfall of 88 parking spaces
compared to the
council's maximum standards and um
the original proposals didn't have any
accessible spaces
i've seen in the additional information
that there is some further proposals
there but i'm not sure
they're still adequate there's an easy
solution to this there's a council on
car park on on oakland's drive it's
about 300 yards away
it's got 60 spaces and you're lucky if
you see a handful of cars on there at
any time
so it's you know clearly within the
bench possibility to make some use of
that
and there's a particular impact on
brighton grove and howells avenue
that's referred to in the report that
you have a paragraph one four three two
one four five
the loss of the pay and display spaces
in particular
is a concern because they are used by
businesses on cross street
now i agree with the report when it says
the businesses don't have a right to use
that parking for their
customers and and deliveries but that
doesn't fully assess the problem that
there is in that particular location
which is that you know i've had
complaints from businesses on that part
of cross street
about uh access parking areas being
blocked
and occupied that's a that's an existing
issue now but that's only going to get
worse
if those pay and display spaces are
taken away or converted to
resident only parking spaces so that's
the last area of
concern i've i've got here so i've just
urged a committee to
weigh what i think are those additional
adverse impacts in the in the balance
that
um i know you'll have to consider thank
you chair thank you
councillor harley and i i know that
um councillors and bunting have already
indicated what i just wanted to say
before that is
um reflecting on what mr wilson's
statement
sort of um touched on and then also
contributions with council alum and
councillor hartley
it does seem to me that there's a lot of
concern um
that largely rests on issues to do with
highways
and i i feel quite conscious i made a
point of looking at the
lha consultation responses uh on the
planning portal
uh and you know the conversation between
the lha and the planning
uh department it was a robust
conversation
but i think a lot of the information is
coming really quite late in the day
and so i don't know mr pearson if
perhaps you can reflect on
and provide a response to some of the
concerns raised by uh
the two councillors there and mr wilson
um
i think perhaps you might want some time
to
before you do so i can call cancel the
minutes before
if that's easier um
i i can comment on that now chairman if
if you wish
i mean i may i may need some assistance
from um
uh i'm happy to comment now
just um just before you do so i've just
this
that there is a speaker in favor of the
application of miserablitch
hi there sorry as well which i was
married
um you've got three minutes to speak um
and if you do everyone
on your time uh i will just politely ask
that you wrap up
okay thank you you can hear me just
checking before i start
yeah good um good evening everybody
and my name is alice routledge and i'm
the planning consultant representing
trafford council and sudden developments
who are joint applicant for this full
planning application
firstly i'd like to thank the officers
for their really hard work throughout
this process
and the recommendation for approval this
site is very important for sale
and a significant level of consultation
with officers stakeholders and the local
community has been undertaken
the project team have taken great care
to sensitively design the proposals for
84 new homes and a new pocket park
and meetings with officers have been
both positive and productive
helping to hone the design proposals
through an iterative process
good design is an integral part of
sustainable development and the density
and scale of development proposed is
wholly appropriate to its context
and will make an efficient use of the
site and enhance the street scene and
character of the area
the proposals include 46 townhouses and
38 apartments
will contribute towards trafford's
housing requirements through the
delivery of a mix of one two
three and four bedroom dwellings and a
policy compliant level of affordable
housing
equating to a minimum of 21 new
affordable homes
no objections are raised by the
council's housing officer
all of the houses benefit from one or
two car parking spaces
an appropriate level of car parking is
also provided for the apartments and for
visitors to the development in light of
the site sustainable location
56 secure cycle space is provided for
the apartments which exceeds the
council's policy requirement
and cycle storage for houses is included
within the garages and secure cycle
stores in rear gardens
the reconfiguration of the gyratory will
provide a simplified highway layout
which is much more akin to the
residential nature of the area
no objections are raised by the
council's highway department
all other key matters have been
addressed including environmental
protection
archaeology ecology drainage and fire
safety
the officer's report is comprehensive
and confirms that no objections are
raised by any internal or external
consultae
and it addresses all the material
considerations
in summary the proposed development will
be high quality and will secure a number
of benefits
including the redevelopment of a
predominantly vacant brownfield site in
a sustainable location
a high quality housing development of
sustainable design and construction
a minimum of 25 of new homes will be
affordable
co2 target reduction of 5 above the
current building regulations
including for example electric vehicle
charging points for all of the houses
solar panels for the apartments air
source heat pumps
mechanical ventilation and timber frame
construction
appropriate levels of car and cycle
parking given the site's sustainable
location close to bus stops and sail
metro link
the provision of a publicly accessible
pocket park and public realm linking the
site to sail town
centre financial contributions towards
education
local open space provision for children
young people
outdoor sports facilities and off-site
habitat creation and locality
and economic benefits arising from the
construction occupation of the new
dwellings
traffic council and said in developments
recognize the importance of this site
and are committed to delivering a
well-designed high-quality development
that will establish a strong
sense of place thank you for your time
this evening and i respectfully request
that you resolve to grant full planning
commission in line with your office's
recommendation
that's it thank you chair thank you uh
ms ralph mitch
[Music]
um so with that in mind conscious that
i did just before them from the speaker
in favor
request that mr pearson at some point um
this evening do respond to
the representations that we received
speaking against the application
um but opening the debate council of
minnesota indicated like to speak
yes thank you chair um so when i was
looking at this i like the idea
obviously
i think it's a great site to redevelop
for a brownfield site for
um housing supply um concerns i have
basically
we have looking at us thinking well i
know that there's a tiny little park but
there's no
in the new development it doesn't seem
although it looks nice there doesn't
seem to be
any um green spaces planned in there
um so whilst it looks very nice it seems
appears that it's probably possibly over
development to the site there's another
reason
why i say that um the road layout is
obviously changing because of the
the gyratory thing um being
being lost effectively um but
i don't know whether the roads are going
from
one you know one way to two-way
which whilst you may widen the road
slightly
um how you'll fit bicycles going both
directions
and cars um it's a recipe for disaster i
don't think i
certainly wouldn't want to cycle on
there um i think that if
we're trying to get people to cycle more
walk more we need to provide
make that easy and safe for people to do
so so
we need to have a different plan um
there's i have massive reservations over
the safety of walking and cycling which
is the way
we are looking for people to go we're
looking to have a reduction in cars
maybe people have one car per household
and people favor walking and cycling
um you know i have concerns over whether
there's school spaces and nearby primary
school spaces for people to be able to
walk their children to school
um there's lots of concerns i i'm hoping
that
maybe my concerns will be um you know as
it were dealt with and i'll feel
positive more positive about it
i'd like to feel positive about it but
i've to me i'm thinking it's probably
over development of the site and it
needs a bit of a
re-look at but thank you very much
thank you council minis and council of
hunting
thank you chairman um
oh the initial thoughts i had with this
one was yes
great that's the site that needs to be
redeveloped everyone
appreciates that the building that was
there
was very much a single purpose building
it wasn't anything you could use for any
other
real purpose and so yeah leveling it and
redeveloping it was always
going to be the way to go um it's just
unfortunate
very unfortunate that it's been done in
the way that's been suggested
at the moment um the biggest problem
the major i go let's get it out of the
way first is as council alum
very accurately reflected it was the
sort of green space
the generator that's been going to be
built straight over
yes i appreciate it's technically
possible to do that but then again it's
council that's doing it
and we talk endlessly about green spaces
in planning committee
and we are walking straight into the
charge of rampant hypocrisy
on this point uh yeah say one thing
do another one rule for one one rule for
the other
disregard our own regulations at the
drop of a hat just because it's
convenient for ourselves
every time we speak to any developer
about this in the future
all we're going to get is this issue
then thrown straight back in our faces
and that's just simply for our own uh
purposes in the future
and he's not taking into account the
substantial loss of immunity that i
think the residents in that area will
suffer
it is as has been pointed out one of the
few green spaces in the area
i drive well i used to drive past it
very regularly before the lockdown
occurred
when i was on my way to work and i'm
sure i will do again in the future
and i used to regularly see people using
that it was hardly a
green space it wasn't well used it was
you'd often see people
people using using that space dog
walking etc
so i don't think that it's acceptable
yes we need to get the um
this site we develop i don't think it's
acceptable to include that
area in it you could develop this site
perfectly well
with without using this second parcel of
land just build on
the other section one uh and deal with
that so redesign it to work that way
um i'm i'm also far from convinced
as a second point regarding the traffic
flow that has been pointed out
and the way that it will work and when
council minister mentioned you ever
suddenly turning one way into two ways
and expecting it all to work especially
if you're trying to encourage
cycling uh um and that neatly brings us
on to a third problem parking
uh substantial shortfall and parking and
then let's admit it that yes i accept
people may
choose to for example go to work on the
bus or or walk to whoever but they're
going to own a car a lot of the time
even if they're not using it on a daily
basis to go to to go into uh
to go into work when i used to look at a
different place that i do now did use
try using the [ __ ]
uh to get to work but um i still owned
the car
and so i still had something to park it
during the week um
and that in turn brings me on to another
problem that i have with this
and i know this is a common air problem
in in many areas of
of traffic i don't think we've used
residents only car parking very wisely
in the past i think we've
we've fouled it up one time after
another we simply go for
broadbush non-thinking uh nine to five
you know all day solves a problem but
then again you then turn up to maybe try
and use an area like cell town center
and you drive into these abandoned roads
during the day
in the middle of that when everyone's at
work uh and the case nine to five monday
to friday with
well on sometimes including saturday as
well now what would be far more sensible
maybe to say change the residence only
parking
so that you were allowed to park for say
two hours uh during the day
because everyone's at work they then
arrive back at five o'clock
they leave work at say five and come
back and yes the
resident tony parking is mr person said
it could be extended into the evening
or what would be maybe a good idea to
extend it into the evening
but i'll i'll join between nine to five
say two hours
parking so that people could come there
when the roads are empty during the day
when people are at work and then use
that as a short stay car park to dip
into
and to sell and it will block people
from uh from parking all day there
you know arriving back late after work
uh
and thus causing a problem for the
residents but we never seem to do this
we seem to have this hang up on oh just
put a whole block plan here that'll do
don't think about it too much just put
it down to five and problem solved
but then that creates all kinds of other
problems for people and we keep talking
about trying to encourage the use of
cell town center
or how on earth is uh are we doing that
through this
through this method and so generally
overall
i think this is a very much a missed
opportunity and
one final problem i really do have with
it and it's so disappointing given the
prominence of the site the design could
be so
much nicer the the houses the pitch
moved houses uh they're they're nice i
like those they look very nice
the blocks of the blocks on the a56
they're okay they could be a bit nicer
though they're not the prettiest things
in the world are the bits of big
square blocks and okay they've got a
chamfered corner and all i can think
what's quite with that green paneling
around it i'm not entirely certain
but the main problem it looks almost
like is those internal buildings on the
on on the though down the center
it looks almost like somebody put lots
of effort into the pictures
buildings then sort of did some work on
the blocks and by the time they don't
know that they really couldn't be
bothered to do any more work and they
thought i'll just shove these things in
they'll do
they fill up the space uh they really
don't go with the rest of the
development they
really don't look nice and given this
location and it's prominence
it'll be so nice to see a really high
per really good
uh development on this location it's so
prominent you're not gonna have to miss
it so
overall chairman i'm bitterly
disappointed with it
and i i think it's got lots of problems
and the green space is really the
crowning
problem of them all and i can't support
this as it stands
yes this site needs to be redeveloped uh
yes that
needs to be done to a high standard but
this is not it
what i would love to see will be the uh
will be a new design formulated comeback
there's something really worth having
something that will look great in the
center of sales something that will be a
real asset
uh and on that basis chairman i'm going
to move
for the reasons i've just outlined i'm
going to move refusal i certainly can't
back it as it is expect yeah
uh you know for the reasons i've just
outlined uh
very disappointing chairman i'm i'm
really i'm just bitterly disappointed in
this one
thank you so much thank you councillor
um councillor curry
uh thank you chairman um i just wanna
get in my head that the applicant for
this is trafford council
trafford metropolitan borough council
along with a partner and this council is
now asking
us councillors to go against the three
ward councillors
to remove green space and
councillor lam indicated about the
education area i'm gonna bring it up
again i could do
every single time we come to this uh
area
of sale and uh primary school places in
particular
this is not enough money there still is
no plan i asked it to be brought up
at the children young person scrutiny
committee there is no plan for education
in this area
for provision i will say openly this
council is now asking us to vote
to build properties where
it will make the local residents lives
worse
uh and that is why i will also be
supporting this uh councillor bunting
in refusing this application thank you
thank you councillor
thanks joe um yeah
i'm actually quite positive about this
uh application
i mean one of one of the concerns i do
have
is i think this council should be
building carbon zero developments
and i'm afraid um this application
doesn't promise that
um the development only should only
needs to demonstrate a minimum of
um a co2 reduction of five percent above
building regulations
um and we know that any of the
initiatives that have been mentioned
are subject to commercial viability
pressures
um i think the mppf is quite clear that
we should be moving towards a low carbon
and renewable technologies and also
we've we've
passed a climate emergency in this
council so we should be creating
space for walking and cycling and
but this this development does offer
some good things it
offers um mechanical ventilation heating
recovery
which i'm i'm very much agreeable to
bring fresh air in
into uh into the buildings and
apartments
um heating pumps good insulation and air
tightness but i think we need more
certainty about the carbon reductions
and we should be aiming for much higher
as a council
so on the energy efficiency i am quite
disappointed that we don't have a bit
more certainty on it and we aren't
aiming higher
um but there are some real positives to
this application
if you look at the affordable housing is
25
which is bang on policy compliant
and the actual mix as well
of the type of affordable housing is
good um
30 8 will be houses
um which is very very good
um and also eevee charging so there'll
be evie charging points for
every uh house or apartment with a
dedicated parking spot
and uh an ev charging point for every 10
car parking spaces which i
which i think is good and i'm also
favorable towards the contributions as
well
um you know there's some good
contributions to
outdoor sports facilities uh local open
space which i think will mitigate some
of the green space that's been
being lost and also to schools as well
um i was a little bit disappointed about
the small allocation for
broad east local nature reserve i
thought that could be higher
uh to offset some of the ecological
impact on the green spaces being lost
um but there were a couple of things
um that do worry me that the loss of the
number of trees
which was always difficult for an area
such as this
um and also i always worried about
flooding
and i think we were told that we would
receive
the united utilities response would be
included in the additional information
report
but i can't see it i don't know if i've
missed it but it would be good
to see united utilities um response
just to work out you know what they're
saying about uh drainage and flooding
issues
but overall i think um on balance in in
favor of this application and
and probably would be swayed towards uh
approving it thanks chair
thank you councilwood councillor win
stanley
uh thank you chairman i think um
briefly what other members of the
committee have said i
i've read the recent proposal with a
great deal of positivity he's got it
it's got a lot going for it there's
21 affordable units on brownfield sites
um the contributions as council jerome
says
i think uh are excellent including the
contribution to priority secondary
schools
places it's been a sustainable very
accessible location
um in terms of public transport
and normally objective whether it's an
annual car parking spaces because i
think technically there are adequate car
parking space in this development but
i'm fast coming around to the opinion
then if you don't build car parking
spaces people don't use cars
and they know it's chicken and eggs i'm
less concerned about that so lots of
positive things
but but um some of the points raised by
um councilman hartley the lack of
community involvement
concerned me there are some losses of
green space
and issues around walking and stacking
infrastructure i think perhaps we can do
better
so at the moment i have 50 50 on this i
think it's a brilliant idea
it's a good location lots lots too lots
to recommend it
but there's a lot of furniture
thank you councillor and council
accordingly
uh thank you chair um it's
it's a difficult one it's it's a town
centre location um
so it's got a good density for that in
many ways it really fits
a town center location i there's
lots to lend itself to this i i do echo
uh some of the comments about uh the
attractiveness uh in
in terms of um cross street um
and the the the uh blocks at the front
but
i think i measure on balance
i would accept those um
the loss of the roundabout um
i struggle with this one i know it's
green space but it is around about at
the same time
um i haven't
seen i mean i've used it a lot it's not
i have to say it's not cycle friendly
that directory
um i've used it
probably more in on the bike than i have
on
car um but um
it's not particularly cycle friendly and
i've been frightened on it
um because it it's
it's it's a difficult maneuver for a
cyclist
again similarly with the council of
ministers comments about
one-way street becoming two-way streets
um
from a cyclist's point of view i hate
one-way streets
they're really weird for a cyclist
because
you're almost naturally stuck to the
left
but you're having to move to do a right
turn
you have to move right over which is
unnatural for a cyclist
but even more importantly it seems
unnatural for the car
drivers around you um so i
from my experience the worst place to
cycle is on a one-way
street even on rungs you know because
you're having to go on the wrong side of
the road
which is weird um and he doesn't feel
safe at all
so i prefer two-way um it's a more
natural environment
on balance i'm going to propose
acceptance i
i think it has there are lots of sort of
hesitations on there but i think i would
propose
it to be accepted simply because i think
it's been through
proper process i think there has been
consultation
um nobody's ever going to be happy with
the things at the end
and there's always going to be problems
at the end but on balance i think it's a
worthwhile
and that's the sale town center it's
it's a reasonable density of um
so i'm going to propose acceptance um
not with a huge not with absolute
enthusiasm but i think on balance it
needs to be accepted
thank you chair thank you councillor
councillor morgan
thank you chair um council accordingly
said this is a difficult one and it is
um councilwood stanley said he was 50
50. and
i i i can echo some of the comments on
that
there are some real positives and it is
it is a town centre location
and there is a density there and it's
building on a brownfield night and i
think there's nobody who's on this
um um soon core who will disagree with
bill building homes on that
but i think councillor bunting said that
it's disappointing and i think it is
disappointing
um council jerome mentioned about for
affordable housing and it's bang on
policy
this is a trafford council scheme a
flagship traffic council scheme and
where all we're doing is bang on policy
um there's uh council alum and
councillor
um harding um said about
cycling infrastructure the highways i
will refer to them as i
i'm by no means to be experts in that
area um to lose an open space
um i think it's quite shocking on a
council scheme
um i'd be disappointed if it was a
completely private development but
um there's two things that kind of
really
i'm really really concerned about which
they are again i'll
echo what counselor um carey said about
school places
um there's a real gain on a big scheme
and it comes again and again and again
in a real
shocking language about stark language
about the
the the the the lack of school places
in the local area but parking
um this is way way under
i mean is it a shortfall of 88 spaces
and we're proposing we might we're going
to have a look at it after we've
approved yet to meet the impact on on
local roads there are roads not far
off where i i think there's a real risk
around these
and people will yeah i live far closer
to the tram stop than um than this
scheme
and most houses around me i only have we
only have one car but a lot of cars
a lot of houses have two or three or
even more
um and there's a real risk on on
um on neighboring residents and i am
really rested reticent approve a scheme
which is going to be
so adverse to some of the the residents
who've maybe lived there for a very very
long time
so i mean i've not decided but i really
do think it's
kind of somewhat it's a really missed
opportunity for a flagship scheme with
the council
and thank you chair
thank you councillor and just for the
purposes of the live stream and the
recording council thomas if you
indicated in the chat that
you wish to second the proposal put
forward by
council accordingly can you just confirm
certainly chair yes i do second that uh
i don't wish to speak on it i think he's
breaking the office from the plans um
miss coley i know that you've said you'd
like to just tell us some points so are
you happy to do so after counsellor dr
bart he's
spoken um possibly it might inform what
what
members say further so um it's and i
also understand that you probably still
want mr pearson to speak on that on the
highways
i just um just reminded to members that
we shouldn't be holding the council to
higher standards through the planning
committee
than other developers um if
a scheme is policy compliant in terms of
affordable housing
as a planning committee that's all you
can ask for as members of council
you can ask for more when these schemes
come come forward as schemes that are
being
brought forward by the council as as an
applicant
but um your remit this evening
is to determine this application in
accordance with
relevant local and national planning
policies
the core strategy um policies and
policies in the mppf
um not to apply um
what you think the council should be
doing which which may
you know may well be the aspirations
that the council will and should have
but at the moment we have a local plan
and that's what we should be determining
a planning application in accordance
with thank you
thank you mrs coley um councillor dr
barbara
thank you chairman um yes i i obviously
this is a really difficult decision i do
welcome the affordable housing i think
that's really really important that we
um
we do achieve good levels with that but
um
for me one of i mean one of the things
that's been mentioned that not
particularly strongly
is the appearance of the development i
think it's really really disappointing
for me it just looks like the old
courthouse
turned into a block of flats and it's
incredibly
unimaginative it's such a shame that the
developers haven't taken this
opportunity
and to really think of something
interesting
and gay and creative for the residents
who have to live
with it and i really think for me is one
of
the biggest negatives of the entire
scheme and i do worry about the other
things
that have been raised by other members
but i'll just leave it there thank you
chair
thank you and councillor dr bartley i
will ask
mr pearson in a moment to comment on
some of the issues around
highways because and whilst they haven't
been
touched on that much during the
discussion they were mentioned quite
uh at length during the representations
that we received
if possible councillor jerome has also
raised a question about the
supplementary and clarification about
the united utilities
response uh consultation response if
we're aware of that
and it would be much appreciated what i
would just say
to members is i can hear a lot of people
saying that this is a difficult
application and
you know there are pros and cons and
it's a shame that it's not perfect but
my own view is that um you know
having served on committee for some time
now i can't recall
an application that's ever come before
committee that i've considered to be 100
perfect the planning process is always
something of a negotiation and you can
give on one thing and gain on another
thing
i think you know this is a development
which is a range of different
accommodation
types in terms of size in terms of
tenure i think that it allows for
townsend to deliver
a town center living in a really
sustainable location
and i think that it's been delivered on
a brownfield site
that isn't currently in use um
outside of those benefits in terms of
bringing lamb back into use
there are other additional benefits that
i think other members have
touched on slightly and one that i think
perhaps hasn't been given no
attention is the um
positive aspects of the development in
terms of energy performance
you read through paragraph 76 to 79 of
the report
you see that some really impressive
words gone into
trying to make this um an energy
efficient development and you don't see
that routinely in developments of this
scale and i think actually perhaps the
report understates the work that's gone
on there
in addition to that i think you know
other members have talked about um
the affordable housing provision but
much beyond that when you look at the
contributions that have been secured by
officers
in terms of um open space play areas
outside sports facilities education
provision and habitat creation
you know the monies that are outlined
there on page 179 of the before
they're really significant you know i
think a huge amount of weight must have
gone into securing that
and so i absolutely agree with what
members have said in terms of you know
there are aspects of the application
that are disappointing
i i'm a little bit concerned about um
the development not being policy
compliant in terms of separation
distance
i was disappointed that greater
manchester fire and rescue services
um consultation feedback in
advice regarding uh sprinkler systems
being installed in the
blocks of flats was completely
disregarded it seems to me that that's
such a cheap measure that a developer
could easily
incorporate into development at this
size
that is really effective in terms of
fire prevention and fire mitigation
and ultimately is there to protect
residents and to protect assets and yet
the developer's chosen not to go with it
so but to me
that is what the planning process is
like commit every single time we come to
committee we have to make those
difficult decisions
and so i i find myself personally
minded to support the application i
think i'm prepared to listen to what
other people have to say
um but with that i'm conscious i've
rambled on at length now i can see
councillor
acton is waving at the screaming are you
looking to contribute counsellor
oh i think he might be on mute
thank you chair um yeah i mean i
i'm supportive of the development um
and we all know there's a massive
housing shortage
um in the borough and across the country
uh this is a town centre development
um it's on brownfield site
uh we're providing in this 25
of affordable homes there are many
positives uh i think councillor jerome
mentioned a number of those so
i'm not going to repeat that and these
contributions to provide
extra school spaces um
and i think the the design
although not absolutely perfect i think
it does
improve that area of sail town center
uh enormously so all in all
i i'm very you know positive about
this application and uh and we'll be
supporting it
thank you
thank you and councillor bunting you've
indicated you'd like to make a further
contribution
yes it's perhaps just wonderful i just
come in after council acting there i
think perhaps
uh chairman we should organize some sort
of prize maybe
the greatest use of understatements uh
in the planning committee meeting not
absolutely perfect
the design for this that is yeah
undeniably true not perfect not by a
very long way but the only thing i
wanted to point out to communities we
have got a great deal of past history in
relation to this with the various
sites around trafford where we've seen
high-profile uh planning
applications come forward with very
lackluster designs
uh you know so it's almost as if
developers like to test
uh what they can get away with and the
fact that we're part of this is making
it equally shaming on this occasion
we then refuse those applications and
then suddenly literally the next
planning meeting along
the completely different planning
applications far better
it looks far nicer suddenly materializes
out of thin air as if by magic
uh giving one example not very far away
just next to the metrolink station in
the center for sale
i'm sure those of us who build this
funding committee are welcome remember
the monstrosity that was proposed for
that
site it got refused and the council
willingson speaking most eloquently at
that meeting
it got refused and almost immediately
straight away a completely different
design it looks absolutely nothing like
the previous one suddenly appeared you
know
in that way so i am not suggesting that
just because this application is no good
this site shouldn't be redeveloped uh it
should most certainly
develop i don't think you'd take a great
deal of effort to try and improve
on what we've got the only other thing i
would decide to point says i must appear
unless i've gone deaf that i appear to
have slipped into a parallel universe
because if i'm not mistaken chairman
i've just heard the green party
counsellor
argue for the building over the last
green space in the area
i'm sure i must have misheard that so uh
um
maybe councillors europe must move
parties i don't know
but um yeah is most most interesting
thank you chairman
councilman thomas thank you jay i'll be
very brief
i think that the the design of the
plans are very good i think it will
install a community spirit within
the whole design and to be quite honest
the green space that we're talking about
and going away
is the center of a roundabout it is not
long
ago four years ago that a huge chunk of
green space was to be sold off
without any query from we've now managed
to
clarify councillor jerome's question
regarding the united utilities
response in terms of flooding was it
yeah chairman i can i can answer that i
mean we we simply haven't had a further
response from
from united utilities um you know uh
further to their initial response the
scheme has however been looked at
by the lead local flood authority you
are you know the main body responsible
for
for drainage uh on the scheme and they
are content
with drainage proposals so i don't think
uh there needs to be any concern about
about drainage on site
thank you um
in terms of where where i understand
that we're at
now then and there has been a motion
proposed and seconded that
the application be approved i've been by
council accordingly in councillor thomas
that there has been a counter
motion proposed by councillor bunting
that the application be refused
um i haven't recorded a second to that
motion i believe chairman councillor
carey did that chairman i can see him
indicating that um
i think every member is spoken
um is there anybody looking to make any
the contribution to this item before
yes chairman if i may if although i i'm
disagreeing with granting if we are to
grant it
uh i would suggest that as i made the
point earlier
that in order to try and assist the town
center we're always talking about the
sistine town centers
that we review that residence scheme in
the way the parking scheme in the way
that i suggested
simply broad brush blanket all day
when the majority of residents aren't
there during the day they're at work
but they need to come back and be able
to park when they return so they don't
want people parking
all day to go and work elsewhere uh so
you but you don't need to put to block
people working parking all day to work
elsewhere you don't need nine to five
you could have say nine to f
say nine to seven even extend it later
well then say you're allowed to park for
a couple of hours so the people who
wanting to use it
short term during the day who are
think your points understood counselor
what what i suggest is perhaps
mr pearson if you could come back on
that and just a number of members have
sort of
suggested that they're unsure about
their thinking perhaps you could just
reflect on
some of the points that have been raised
if possible
yes phil thank you sharon um yeah i mean
i i sense perhaps the thing that seems
to have been raised most is the loss of
the gyratory so
perhaps just by way of explanation from
officers as to why
we felt it was appropriate to recommend
approval of the scheme
um i mean the land isn't open space
um you know it is it is a it is a road
system
um it's one that i know well as a
planner and and as a resident who lives
in sale
um and i think to our way of thinking
um it's a bit of broken streetscape
basically
the the roundabout there isn't a strong
streetscape there and we saw this as an
opportunity to introduce a much more
attractive streetscape
defined by both the strong presence of
buildings particularly down ashton lane
to to know to sort of continue that
presence that you have further towards
ashland village and an opportunity to
introduce some street trees
to create an attractive street scene um
the tree loss obviously on the site is
regrettable
and that again really has come about
largely
as a result of looking to repair this
broken street student to create a strong
straight frontage so the tree loss is
regrettable obviously but there are
a considerable number of new trees
proposed
including a lot of street trees um
i understand the points raised in
particular by
councillor hartley um about the
sort of uh missed opportunity to create
and improve pedestrian and
cycling uh opportunities
um i think in terms of pedestrian
linkages
um from ashton village towards sail town
center
i think the creation of this uh
street tree-lined routes and the
creation of the new route
will actually be a great benefit and i
think it will improve it
will cr would create a much improved
pedestrian environment
but they acknowledged that you know the
scheme didn't look at creating
uh an improved cycling network and a
sense perhaps that's that
needs to be part of a larger piece of
work
um in terms of obviously businesses
expressing concern about the loss of
parking or brighton grove
there are obviously a considerable
number of towns center car parks
uh within a very short walk of
those businesses the uu response serve
i'd covered um the community involvement
i think again from our perspective as
officers there
as applicant the council undertook a
really
quite extensive consultation exercise um
and we have done likewise as we would do
as a planning authority
on an application of this scale
in terms of the um the sort of highway
point so perhaps i
i will try and summarize them and
and if um if mr edenson feels that he
wants to
add to that then obviously he can do
we're obviously aware that there's been
strong representation made in respect to
the highway issues
particularly the loss of the gyratory
and specific
concern in relation to highway safety
but the local highway authority
is happy that the transport assessment
submitted with the application
was robust and that the loss of the
gyratory
won't have an adverse impact on the on
the highway network either in terms of
the free flow of traffic or pedestrian
or driver safety
and to that and a road safety audit was
undertaken
and a number of amendments i understand
have been made to the proposals
during the course of the application on
the back of that
in terms of merchants in terms of
emergency vehicles leaving the
the fire and ambulance stations on
cromwell drive
i mean they were notified about the
application as was the gm fair and
rescue service
no objections received whilst cranley
drive
is proposed to be marked as a single
lane there's going to be no reduction in
the width of carriageway so
there would be plenty of room for
emergency vehicles
traveling along cranley drive and being
able to
exit onto ashton lane without any delay
the strategy of the highway within the
site uh a point recommended by the
again by the fire and rescue service
that now forms part of the proposal
um and likewise in terms of the concerns
expressed about queuing traffic
um the highway authority haven't
assessed the transport assessment
i'm happy that that that won't happen
uh between the planning authority and
highway authority
planning authority we think the level of
parking provision is considered to be
acceptable given
the location of the site i know it's an
easy argument to make to say
a site is is in a sustainable location
but um there are two parking spaces
proposed for all the houses on ashton
lane
all of those on york road and those on
whittle street
and then one parking space for each of
the houses on brighton grove
the shortfall obviously is really mainly
in relation to
apartments where 12 spaces are provided
for
38 apartments um
the traffic regulation order um council
blunting spoken about
uh on a couple of occasions um i mean
that would be
subject to consultation with residents
so
there's no hard and fast proposal uh
put before you there tonight that would
be a traffic regulation order which
would be subject to a consultation
exercise
and any views expressed as to how that
would best work
um could be could be considered at that
point
um i think that's as much as i can say
on on those matters i hope i've covered
most of the issues that the the members
have raised thank you chairman
thank you uh counselor minister uh it's
just asked if you can
ask a question so thank you chair um so
just thank you very much mr pearson for
for that it's answered a lot of the
concerns i had at the beginning um one
question is about
just the so when when the roads are
going from one way to two-way
um obviously the road's going to get
narrower it all
how um how are we going to be able to
have cyclists going both ways is it
um in a safe way that they're not going
to get run over
basically so that was what my my
question
i hope that makes sense yes thank you
kaz
yes um i mean yes there's there are a
couple of
short stretches of road that are going
to change from from one way to two ways
so there's
there's a length on uh york road uh
between ashton lane and palace road
and then there's a length on ashton lane
between park road and um cranley drive
basically
that's currently generatory so yes they
would become
two-way um and they would operate in the
same way that any other two-way road
operates you know so there aren't any
concerns about that there has been a
road safety audit undertaken
so i mentioned i think a few minutes ago
that amendments to the scheme were
introduced
on the back of that and
any changes obviously would also be
subject to to the detailed highway
design
where there will be a requirement to
look to make the design
as safe as it can be
thank you very much thank you um
there's no other member indicating that
they'd like to
speak now and we have had motions moved
on
in support of approval and refusal
um before we take the vote on refusal
perhaps we can just clarify exactly what
um reason to edit because there's been a
lot of concerns raised
um but i'm just conscious that i don't
think some of them
will be particularly strong uh planning
grounds reviews also
thinking about school places for
instance so perhaps i don't know if
council of bunting or councillor carrie
can just clarify exactly what
grounds for refusal they'd like their
motion to be based on
yes chairman more than happy to i mean
certainly in terms of the
application the uh immunity loss i know
people keep saying that the
the green space is the center of a
roundabout but that's not entirely
accurate given the
local geography yes there is a road when
you around it's not like a standard
roundabout
uh it is well used and i feel there will
be a very substantial loss of immunity
especially given the fact that it is the
only
green space if it were one of several
green spaces in the immediate area you
would have
far less of a planning argument but
given the fact that it's that
is it then you are then i believe that
will be a substantial issue
i also have some serious concerns
regarding
parking issues given the fact that he's
such a shortfall yes i know his
counselor
uh sorry not counsel i do apologize as
mr pearson
said i wouldn't uh damn you with the
epithet of counselling mr pearson
um uh as mr pearson says yes
the argument is near a sustainable
location is an easy one to make
uh as i explained myself before i used
to live in this
not very far from here and i used the
car and i used to get
public transport into manchester every
day but i still had a car and it still
had to be parked somewhere
and i think that would be a case in the
fact that it's a but it's a flat
that was talking about with the under uh
under a provision of parking don't
believe that that will be an issue
the parking the traffic is sure that
people have said that they're a little
be fine and
everything's going to be wonderful with
it but i still do have some concerns
with that directory wasn't put in for a
laugh
i was putting for a good reason at the
time and i
think the way that we're moving to that
now is it is going to be
um uh very much a problem um
although now there is also the
accumulative impact
on the constantly putting new houses
into this area
constantly jacking up the without
sufficient uh
educational uh uh backup uh i
know you say that's a weak reason but i
still think it is there in the mix if it
was the only reason you might have a
a good point but it's one of several and
it's accumulative impact
uh that's a if it has over time for each
individual application okay it wouldn't
go as a problem but there's one after
another after another after another and
this is one of several arguments against
this site it's not the only one
thank you gentlemen
thank you and counselor so uh
just attempted to make my own notes
though i i clocked lots of immunity
parking traffic all highways
infrastructure impact
and education ms coley could you just
reflect on mr piston
and if if we're content with those yeah
okay so can i just i understand the the
parking shortfall relative to
the council's maximum standards but just
trying to introduce
trying to understand what harm might
result
because of the parking provision
the traffic regulation orders are
changed to prevent new residents
from parking on existing streets because
that
new residence wouldn't normally be
allowed to have a parking permit
in an existing residence only parking
zone
so we're just trying to understand what
what harm might result there
just as this has been a case of various
other ones you can
displace but you can't eradicate so yes
okay what happens is those people have
to park further away so you
you just push the problem further and
further out
just as it may just as with various
other um
uh just as other sort of uh
parking schemes that we've introduced
around traffic as soon as you create a
parking scheme in one area all you do
is the next door area suddenly gets hit
by a major problem
uh i've had this in my own ward we've
introduced other parking schemes in the
area
and suddenly all that happens is an area
of your own wood which didn't have a
parking problem
now miraculously does you can't resolve
the problem in that way
all you can do is push it about
okay chairman can i just um
just come back on the the amenity loss
the the generatory
um i mean can i suggest that would be
uh a lot of visual amenities of the
generator because it isn't classed as
open space
but it is also you i i say i know you
live
in the area mr pearson uh as do i i
drive past it regularly and you do
often see people walking for example
dogs on that area
it is heavily used for that purpose now
i appreciate that
might not have been the original intent
uh
i know council thomas is there shaking
his head wildly in the background
uh but uh i'm afraid you can shut your
head all you like it won't stop the fact
that it's true
uh the point is i drive out regularly
you do see
people park using that area for say for
example dog walking
uh what have you it's the if it was
one of several green spaces in the air
you could say this is not
intended as an open green space it's
purely part done in that way
but it is that or nothing so that's what
people use now there will therefore be
an immediate loss of
yes i probably accept there is a visual
immunity issue i
have already alluded to the fact that
the design is extremely disappointing
and the pocket park is almost adding
insult to injury
it's almost uh it's almost um
it's almost the case of what we're
taking away the only green space in
there and
what we're giving you in exchange it
would almost be better if it wasn't
there
because it almost rubs it in you know
yeah you used to have a green space and
now you've got a mockery of a green
space
and it would be almost better if the
pocket part wasn't there
because that was somebody stand as a
reminder to the people in the area look
out look how much worse things they've
got
chairman can i just come back on one
final point that's the the insufficient
education contribution i mean
uh the scheme does propose a full
education contribution so in that sense
it mitigates its educational impacts it
it provides
money to cover additional school places
for all the children that will be
generated
by the development mr pearson you know
as well as i do that the
schools in the area are pretty much full
most of the schools have already been
extended to allow
additional form entries unless we're
going to get a new school coming out of
somewhere somewhere shortly
there are going to be problems there's
only so many times you can bump up the
number of
kids you allow to enter the existing
schools
there's only so many additional
buildings you can sort of bolt to the
side of the school to allow
additional form entries to go in sooner
or later
though if we carry in the way that we
are we're going to need a new school
in the area not just an extra classroom
bolted to the side of the existence
i appreciate that that's your opinion
but i think this is about generating
strong grounds for refusal and it's
called you've indicated that
you'd like to just comment on um
yes again i would remind that this
decision needs to be made on planning
grounds and there may well be concerns
about a lack of school places
in sale however all we can ask any
development
to do in the area or through the borough
is to make an appropriate contribution
to mitigate its impact
this development mitigates its impact we
cannot ask it but anymore
okay are we content that we've got
grounds for a few years also sort of
clarified that then mr pearson
well i mean i've made a note of the loss
of amenity space
um a shortfall in parking which i'll
assume
um council bluntly was suggesting would
impact on residential immunity of
residents living
beyond the parking zone areas so
so much further down ashton lane um
i think you may have touched on lots of
generator and impacts on highway safety
um but then the as i say the the
education impact as
as mrs coley's just indicated it you
know we can't reasonably refuse an
application when
when it proposes to mitigate its full
impact
it was the point i was making this is a
cumulative
impact and that is an additional
planning application i'd say except the
first three
are the stronger ones but that is a a if
if it were that on its own then i would
certainly agree
but it's not that's a it's an additional
uh effect that he's having if it were
that only then i would agree with you
but the fact that it's uh it's not the
only
it's several items coming together to
cumulatively give a good solid reason
i think the concern is that they're just
not a grounds for refusal
in planning terms the process is that
you seek a contribution
uh following the advice of your
education authority
and then you seek to secure that
contribution which in this case has been
done
i accept that but as i'm saying that's
uh that's uh
something that is is limiting the effect
but i say it's it's certainly not the
only if as i said you before if it was
only that item
then i would agree it wasn't strong
enough to reviews the main reasons for
refusal or the other ones i've given you
that was something additional
okay mr
opinion i think perhaps you just need to
unders to clarify whether or not
um you know the support for
either three or four reasons though
the case should be refused um
in the next vote for those four reasons
it would be all four of those reasons
so if members don't consider any of them
to be
um sustainable then they shouldn't vote
for refusal we can then have an
alternative motion with fewer reasons
for different reasons or however but
but that it members must be convinced
that all four of those reasons are the
reasons they would want to refuse the
application for
okay thank you that that that's helpful
thank you miss coleman okay
i'll move to um the vote then i'll just
cycle through members as you appear on
my screen and this is on
council of bunting's motion that we vote
contrary to officer recommendation
and refuse application permission
this evening and counselor minis
thank you chair although i i don't like
parts of it
um i i accept a lot of the answers that
mr pearson's given me
and i'll be voting um against the
refusal
that way around okay thank you
councillor duran
i'll also be voting against um refusal
the motion to refuse
thank you cancel the bunting
i'm sorry counselor hunting i didn't
hear them
for the refusal thank you and
councillor wins stanley uh thank you
chair voting against the refusal
thank you um councillor thomas
thank you chair voting against the
refusal thank you councillor kerry
i'll be voting for the refusal please
chairman
thank you um council of acting voting
against
the refusal chair thank you
councillor morgan
um for the refusal
thank you council accordingly uh against
the refusal chair
thank you councillor dr berkley
for the refusal chairman thank you
thank you um i will be voting
against the motion to refuse
i think that's everybody
i missed any members there
eleven members voting chairman that's
correct right okay
and that motion is not carried
and there has been a
motion moved by council according to the
encounter and seconded the council of
thomas
uh in support of granting permission
this evening
um we can now move to that though uh
again
i'll cycle view members as you on my
screen
counseling minutes
um i'll be grudgingly vote in in support
of it thank you
thank you uh councillor jeremy i'll be
a supporting recommendation to grant
thanks chair
thank you councillor bunting thank you
chairman
against recommendations grant thank you
councillor winston uh thank you chair
voting for the officer recommendation to
grant
thank you councillor thomas
thank you voting for the officer
recommendation to grant
thank you councillor carey
sorry chairman i'll be voting to uh
against our officer's recommendation
please
thank you um councillor acton
all the recommendations to grant chair
thank you councillor morgan
okay um against um officer
recommendations chad
thank you and councillor accordingly
for the office there's a recommendation
to grant thanksgiving
thank you councillor barclay against the
officer's recommendation
thank you chair thank you and i will
vote
in paper approving
and that motions carried the application
is granted
uh approval um the next
item for consideration this evening is
into
his former handful of nurseries in
waterton which is on page one
of the committee report and before we
move to discussion or representations
it's going to be introduced by ms
collins
[Music]
apologies i'm just sorry i was
struggling both with unmuting myself
and screen sharing so if you just bear
with me
i am trying to
um would uh one of my colleagues be so
kind as to try and
um find the slideshow because i'm
bailing the screen oh have we got it now
is that working yes yeah right thank you
sorry my apologies for that um i was
having a bit of a technology fail there
okay um so this application is the
former pam flora nurseries which is
barnes lane in in washington
um it's a residential redevelopment of
previously developed land
uh which has been vacant since 2018. the
site was a former landscape gardeners
business
known as panflora nurseries it's located
to the northwest of barnes lane which
you can see on there
um just inside the parish of warp is
immediately adjacent to dunamasi and
both warburton parish council and donna
massey parish council
have had significant interest in in this
scheme
you can see on the on the existing site
plan there is is how the
apologies that that is quite faint but
you can see that there are
um um a number of
existing buildings on the site this one
here which is which is
labeled as two is outside the
application so it's about dotted line
you can see there is
the application site boundary you've got
a building there a building there
and you've got um plenty of hard
standing
in in in these areas so it is very much
what we would consider previously
developed land
um these are some images of the site
when it was
occupied in use again you can see this
there's plenty of activity on that site
and those
those buildings are uh that are shown
within that site at red arsenal
um and again these um
these photographs are from the office
case office's site visit um obviously
you see from the trees it wasn't
yesterday but
um more recently and when the site's now
vacant
the area surrounding the site is rural
in character
you've got the closest residential
properties on saw pit street to the east
and there's land to the west the site
there's other properties in the rope and
anchor public house
on paddock lane which is due south the
application site beyond the transpanine
trail or site photographs there
then and this is the proposed site plan
so the development will consist of seven
um two-story detached residential
dwellings
numbered one to seven as you can see
here on on the plan
uh each would either have four or five
bedrooms there'd be associated landscape
access and parking you've got car bars
there and some
some of the properties have got integral
garages
and the developers and applicants have
worked with the local planning authority
and other stakeholders
including both the parish councils
tremendous proposals to seek to address
concerns the proposed number of
dwellings has been reduced from nine to
seven
um and there's a detention basin at the
northern site you can see there
which has been introduced and the
overall layout and design of the
dwellings being amended
so these are the street elevations it's
from barn lane barnes lane
um that one is from within the site so
you can see that
that the um the applicant is proposing a
traditional vernacular style
for these for these applications and
this has taken uh
influence from the warburton village
design guide in doing so and also
advice from officers so again you can
see
um more close-up that's plot one
which is towards the front of the site
but two also towards the front of the
site
you see this diaper detailing here which
is which is very
typical of warperton
uh you've got to see the car a carbine
there
plot four there
five just move through these
seven uh you can see how the car barns
associated with plots one and two which
has an access there but that's balanced
lane there
running through then some
um sketch proposals
and again that diabetes detailing that
you can see
that's typical of orbiting and some
montages from distance
so what year zero and year 15 means that
year zero means
effectively when it's first gone in and
the landscaping is is low and hasn't had
a chance to
to mature so at year 15 obviously any
trees that are planted in the site
hedges and so on will it will have
filled out and matured
and obviously reduce the impact of the
development but i think what that's
trying to show is actually
the impact of the development is fairly
fairly minor in any event
okay so i'll just go back to the site
plan i go
through the rest rest of the what i have
to say
um as i said the sciences in the green
belt uh there are
several definitive exceptions to the
general presumption against development
with green belt
and one of these is the the
redevelopment of brownfield sites
but that has to be where there is no
greater impact on the openness of the
green belt
from the proposals um
officers have carried out a careful
analysis of the
both them its footprint height
um overall massing and an analysis of
the visual effects
and is considered it would fall into
this category and wouldn't have a
greater impact
on openness from from the existing
development which is on there
because there are you know two very
substantial buildings
and large areas of hard standing um
therefore it would fall into one of the
exceptions
which enables development to take place
in green belt it wouldn't comprise
uh what is known in the the mpp of
inappropriate development
and therefore there's no need to
demonstrate very special circumstances
for development to proceed
um it's office's view in this case as it
is appropriate development
and the tilted balance in the national
planning policy framework is triggered
officers also consider that the proposed
development subject to the various
conditions you've seen
in the report would be acceptable in
terms of its design and
appearance its impact on landscape
character residential immunity
contaminated land highway matters flood
risk ecology by the
biodiversity and its landscaping and as
such the epic
thank you chairman thank you
uh ms corley and i think we have uh
david scafe is it speaking against the
application
hello can you hear me yes thank you
i'm pronouncing your surname correctly
um you are indeed thank you brilliant
you've got three minutes to speak and if
you do run over time i'll just politely
try and wrap up your contribution thank
you okay good evening
um i don't have the benefit of the
slides and
and shall we say specially prepared
photographs
that uh miss coley has
my wife and i for whom i speak um have a
visual contact with this site
we agree that the site needs to be used
for housing
however we need to register our concerns
as follows
firstly drainage the experts reports
as submitted by sudden homes the
applicant
r to this layman anyway
gobbledygook spies with a multitude of
acronyms
what we do know from our experience of
living adjacent to the side
is that in winter and spring the fields
and sometimes roads are often deep in
flood water
when your meeting started at 6 30 i was
looking over
two substantial lakes next to the
uh next to the proposed site
uh little recognition seems to have
taken of this
the proposal only transfers the water
elsewhere
and takes no notice of the watercourse
as it goes into
we need the developers to guarantee with
penalties
that this proposal does not add to the
transfer
to the flooded nature of the environment
secondly moving to visual setting
we believe there are too many houses on
the proposal
there will be a maximum there should be
a maximum five and they should be more
compatible
with the character of the surrounding
areas the proposal despite a recent
modification
is disappointing still introducing an
urban
housing estate into a as an eyesore into
a rural setting
warburton is by traffic council's own
definition
and i quote an area of landscape
protection
despite ms cole's words the development
is at odds with traffic guidelines
a better more thoughtful balance is
required towards sustainable development
and to be in line with trafford's own
policies thirdly
boundary fencing the developer has
recently erected
a garish wooden fence across the
northern boundary
of the site we ask if this is indicative
of a future thoughtless attitude to the
greenbelt
and the rural environment we sincerely
hope for the sake of visual
amenity that this is a temporary
structure in a rural area characterized
by mixed house hedgerows it is in breach
of multiple
national and local trafford planning
guidelines
there needs to be formal assurance given
by the developers
that this will be replaced by the
planting of mature species
forming an immediate hedgerow and not by
a row of
whips and stick trees that will take
many years
to form a mature barrier this side was
not covered
although the site was not covered by
miss coley's photographs
the office fourth or fourthly the office
building outside the curtin shown on the
plan
is an isolated existing office building
there is no indication of future plans
for this
or for the woodland next to it there
appears little provision for amenities
such as parking to support its continued
usage
the developers should be asked to make
plain their long-term view for its use
in future development
if only to ensure this does not lead to
traffic
and parking issues in the dangerous rat
run
that barnes lane already is and there
have been many accidents there to prove
that
finally we have a light contamination
we have not found comments concerning
lighting
for the roads on the development or for
barnes lane
will there be any waters and adjacent
thunder
your time is up now i'm afraid but i
think we've
we've got the gist of your argument
there in terms of lighting certainly
have you oh really
thank you for being with us this evening
and i think speaking in favor of the
application is it
charlotte fowler hi yes
hi miss fowler um you'll also have three
minutes to speak if you do one over time
i'll just provide this that you're back
with your contribution thank you
thank you i
this this application is for the
construction of seven houses
on a parcel of previously developed land
formerly used by a landscape contracting
business
and which has been vacant for a number
of years the application is made by
an experienced sme house builder
the application follows two rounds of
pre-app consultation with your offices
and a 12-month
determination period during which the
applicant and team
has worked collaboratively with offices
done in massey parish council and walton
parish council
this has involved detailed local design
input on the layout and housing
designs over a number of meetings and
the result is a well thought out
development which officers
and both parish councils fully support
reuse of the site is appropriate in
policy terms being previously developed
sites
and the proposal is for less building
and development than it exists on site
already
the proposal would see demolition of two
large commercial buildings
and through bespoke design siting and
overall layout there will be a reduction
in built volume of 32 a reduction in
building footprint of 47
and a decrease in hard standing of 41
which overall we and your officers have
concluded that the development will have
no greater impact on openness and in
fact represents an improvement in
openness
we've considered several technical
points raised during the application
process
and on highways the the redevelopment
will result in an overall reduction in
traffic used
and fairly significant when compared
with the existing permitted site use
and will end the need for access to the
sites by htv's down barnslane once the
development is complete
on drainage you understand this has been
a local
concern as you've heard from the
objector um
however the site is a large area of hard
standing
and buildings and impermeable area
and which drains into the local drainage
network and there will be a new drainage
screen
scheme which will introduce new on-site
attenuation
to the water flow and new permeable
areas in the form of gardens and
driveways
which will result in lower uh lower peak
flows into local drainage system which
will be an improvement on the current
situation
there are no objections from statutory
council teas and the lead local flood
authority and highways officer happy
with the scheme
there will also be extensive planting
scheme and introduction of tree planting
and a wildfire
that wildfire meadow which will bring
visual and biodiversity benefits
this scheme is exactly the kind of
previously developed site that
government policy seeks to support to
address the housing crisis
it's a small brownfield site being
developed by a local house builder with
a bespoke design appropriate
to its location and with local support
we hope that you too will support your
officer's recommendation and the views
of your parish councils and vote for the
approval of the application
thank you
thank you ms powell and you can see
councillor jerome you've already
indicated you happy to open the
discussion
on my bike it was rather windy but um
i i'm quite positive about this
application um
i think um one of the most positive
things
is it's seven large family homes on
vacant and
previously developed land i mean it is a
brownfield site and it does need to be
developed on
and there's some quite good things in
there such as ev charging for each
property um storage of four cycling
spaces
uh at each property two and
this is right uh right on the chat
um transpar9 trail as well so you you
would hope that those cycling spaces
would uh
really be kind of used by the property
owners
um and it's great access to you know
cycling into altering them
and off to kind of other places
in in the opposite direction and if you
do look at the drainage plan there is a
suds plan
and it is for the lifetime of the
property um
it it says in the committee report so
i'm kind of thinking that the
the drainage plan has been well thought
through
um and you know hopefully should should
address some of those problems
um and i also i'm really in favor of the
landscaping plan
i i think they've done a good job good
job there
there's going to be um 36 small
medium deciduous trees of horsehawn and
cherry so i think that
well the horse on certainly a native
variety
and there will be larger trees as well
such as birch and beach
um there's going to be an orchard um and
native and ornamental hedgerows as well
as some
wildflower planting and i think the the
landscaping scheme
um it is a very good one and i i
appreciate the work that officers have
done done there and there's
also a an associated maintenance plan
for 10 years on that landscaping scheme
as well which
which i approve of and i i do think
i am sympathetic to um the objectives
comments
um you know there are highways problems
but i don't
know if the development can be held
responsible for
for those and i'm not sure they really
had to add to the highway problems i
think they're probably already there
um but also the objective did did make
the point of lighting
um and that's something i think it'd be
worth to get a response from the
officers on
because light pollution obviously is is
it is a problem
and and we don't want to cause light
pollution in a countryside area
but i would say overall i'm i'm kind of
in favor of this scheme
and and probably will be supporting it
obviously uh
i just like to hear what others have to
say first so thanks jeff
thank you councillor and councillor
minis
thank you chair i look at this and i
thought i thought when i was looking at
the spacing out and i thought
that nine was too many and i think that
the parish councils are right that i
think seven actually
is fine um i really quite like and just
like
like counselor jerome was saying about
the ev
charging of course being electric car
owner myself and
and you've got somewhere for your bike
to go and i think that that's
it's absolutely encouraging uh people
into the right direction
um i quite like the layout i like the
fact that you know you've
we've got we've considered um having the
green spaces around this as well as
um you know as passed as a plot so um
really really quite supportive of that
of it actually light pollution was the
one concern but if we can have an
assessment about that that would be
great um but i'd like to propose that we
grant the application um to support that
officer's recommendation thank you
thank you councillor councillor hunting
i'm more than happy to speak but i
believe
councillor morgan was before me
councilman thanks jared thank you
pennsylvania
um yeah i'm going to echo both cancer
driving council and minnesota i'm
i'm really really positive about this
scheme um and
i i think officers have done a really
really good job um
i i i i will i one thing i really
really will rakko is the highway safety
particularly on barnes lane and dunham
road but i do agree with the comments in
the report that
this is not going to make the problem
any worse it's probably something the
council should be looking at but it is
from a planning point of view there is
no there is certainly not a reason to
vote but i i think certainly the houses
will i look
there's a it's very difficult to make
new houses look old
um but i think certainly um
in terms of what they're replacing at
the moment i think it's they're a real
real improvement um and i think
they're very spacious so i think they're
very much in the keeping of
neighboring properties um yeah i i'm
really really positive so i'm happy to
uh second councillor minister's uh
proposal to
accept officer recommendations thank you
chair
thank you councillor council thank you
chairman before i
make my comments um obviously two
previous speakers councillors german
minister
raised the issue of lighting and it was
one of the
two uh significant points i think really
pulled out from me
objectors uh comments the other being
flooded now whilst i'm satisfied in
relation to flooding with the various
uh measures that have been put in place
i just want to try to find in the report
i can't uh
find how what is the arrangement in
relation to
street lighting of the overvote of these
obviously these new
roads these houses are going to be off i
can't can i get an
answer on that before i make my comments
i know it's been alluded to by two
previous counselors and we said you'll
get offers comments but no officer
comments have yet
been forthcoming in relation to that i'd
like to know that before i
say what i think if i'm a police
chairman do
uh the officers have that information to
hand
yes yes certainly uh counsellor through
you chair
um the there is no uh specific lighting
scheme posed for the uh access roads
um and uh as such um
given the concerns around light
pollution that have been um
by the objectives uh officers
that it was appropriate to deal with
that by condition now that's
um condition 22 in your main report
however the additional information
report
does go slightly further because uh the
applicant said they didn't they didn't
wish for
there to be a restriction on owners
putting security lights
on their homes which is understandable
if it's otherwise a completely dark
environment that you would want some
light to
arise as you as you approached your home
obviously i think it's also
worth pointing out that um although i
couldn't tell you exactly what lighting
there was on the previous
business i'm sure at times there were
headlights and other lights
uh emanating from the site because it is
a brownfield site it
it's unlikely it has ever been at any
point completely dark
um so condition 22 requires the local
planning authority to
agree at a scheme for any external
lighting
other than that that would be installed
on the buildings because the homeowners
would have
their own ability to install lights
on their properties as as as they wished
but anything
street lights or any other lamps would
be
subject to our approval
you chairman i wanted to clarify that
before i moved on yeah i
i think the previous uh amendments have
been
broadly correct i think there's no way i
would have supported this with nine
uh not nine uh but seven i think is
exactly probably the maximum you're
gonna get on there
it might have been better to have had
six but seven is just about crowbared in
and
in in a reasonable way but i think that
he's literally hitting at the very
maximum
uh cycle and that said uh i think the
design is
is a good design i think the as council
morgan points out you're not going to
make the products a little colder
overnight but then you
can design them in such a way that they
will blend in given a period of time
and i think we've pretty much achieved
that so overall
uh i i'm satisfied with that i also
accept the comments made previously
about the fact that yes there are
problems highways wise in this area uh
that
are people using it as a uh but then it
he's part of a road network and people
are using it to get from a to b
in the way that it's intended uh i'd
also accept that this
uh application is not the cause of uh
that uh that issue and it is not gonna
substantially
worsen that issue so i think overall i
can see no real
uh reason why this application should
not be be granted
i'm more than happy to vote in in favor
of that i will just urge the officers
when it comes to uh
approving any conditions for street
lighting should one be put forward that
they
they exercise due caution when doing so
i'm sure they will
thank you chairman thank you councillor
thank you chairman yes i also uh welcome
the application
i think it's really really attractive
especially when we think about what
we're comparing it to with the old
nursery site
and i do really commend the developers
for uh gaining the support of warburton
parish council and dunamasi
parish council i think that speaks
volumes that the two parish councils
and are happy with the development
particularly now it's been scaled back
and it is always good to have new houses
in the bowl we know we need more
i do have just a tiny tinge of regret
over it that
all the houses are really big houses
they're going to be probably very very
expensive they're not really going to
provide a routine
for local warburton or dunamasi
residents to
stay within an area if they wanted to
particularly uh maybe first-time buyers
so
we've got just a little kind of note of
distress about the development i think
really on balance it's absolutely lovely
and really welcome
the development once it's it's built
thank you chair
thank you and counselor
uh thank you chair the risk of entering
an echo chamber i'll also be
uh supporting this for all the reasons
gone before and turning and
brownfield greenfield sites who were
into a rom
uh into housing um the developers worked
with the level
with the local council and the uh the
national trust to remove any objections
um any existing traffic uh will not be
made worse by this
um overall i'll be supporting this so
thank you chef
thank you and councillor culturally i
think you have a question do you
yeah yeah it was just really for
clarification i can read
uh paragraph one three four about
affordable housing
uh contribution um i don't fully
understand it
in the sense that um what makes this not
a major development
um i just wonder if there's some
clarification on that
i understand that uh our local plan is
out of date and therefore
there isn't um we can't insist on that
but
it seems the definition is that it's by
its
nature has been not a major development
what's the definition of a major
development
um it's a major development in warburton
um but that that's probably been
picnic picking it so um
if i could just have a an explanation as
to why we can't extract a
affordable housing contribution uh major
development is
is a specific definition in planning
terms of 10 or more
residential units
fine
i think there's broad support for this
application was called i was just
wondering mr skafe in his
representation referred to fencing
that's been erected
uh and um based the concern that there
wasn't any detail in the plan around
boundary treatment measures on that side
is that something that the planning
authority are familiar with i'm just
wondering
we we have a um and with apologies to
the objector i wasn't quite
quite clear as to which side he was he
was referring to we do have however
a condition which requires all boundary
treatment
to be approved and there is some shown
on the on the plans already particularly
hedging and cheshire railings which
which members will be familiar with
if you've you've been in that area that
is that very traditional
um black and white fencing um metal
fencing that you see
so there is there is there is some
control
so uh position 20 of your reports
so all requires no part of the
development to be occupied
until details of type sighting design
and materials to be used in the
construction of boundaries screens
or retaining walls being submitted to
and approved in writing
and the proof structures need to be
erected in accordance with those
approved details so we are
covering boundary treatment at all
boundary treatments through that
condition
if if mr scape was referring to part um
to uh development outside the site edge
red that's not part of this planning
application we couldn't control it
that that's great and so that qualifies
that and i think we can probably move to
a votes on this item now as it has been
proposed and seconded
the application be granted permission
i'll just cycle three members as you
appear on my screen and
counselor minis i'll vote to
enough to support officers
recommendation to grant thank you
thank you council jerome i support
officer's recommendation
thanks jeff thank you councillor bunting
[Music]
oh i do apologize i'd left myself on me
there uh support officer recommendation
to grant
thank you chairman thank you councillor
hartley
thank you chair i support the officer's
recommendation to grant as well thank
you thank you council winston
uh thank you chair support officer
recommendation to grant
thank you councillor dr berkley support
officer recommendation to grant
thank you thank you councillor
accordingly
support officer's recommendation chair
thank you
councillor carey
a grant police chairman thank you
councillor thomas
support the officer's recommendation
thank you jen thank you councillor
morgan
uh sport officer recommendation to grant
chair thank you
council of acting all recommendations of
officers to graham
thank you and i shall also be voting uh
in line with officer recommendation to
approve
the application and that promotions
carried unanimously
and the next application that we'll turn
to this evening is
landed circle court in lostok which is
on
page 194 of the committee report
and before we receive any
representations the application is going
to
be introduced by ms lowe's thing
thank you and this application relates
to cycle court
or a new hotel development and just
before i get into the presentation
there's just a point of clarification
that i need to make
in relation to the air um within
the additional information report we
have made reference to
um the car parking spaces that's there
the existing circle court residents
and the amounts to be lost as part of
the developments
what we haven't clarified or qualified
there is that there is a scheme
to reprovide those car parking spaces
by trafford housing trust which has been
granted planning permission
so at present there is 65 residential
car parking spaces for the existing
circle court
um residents and thc will be providing
68 new residential and new
new parking spaces as part of their new
scheme so just to make that clear to
residents that there isn't
a complete loss of spaces there will be
a reprovision as part of
a wider application and within the
additional information report as well
there is an additional condition
which requires a car parking management
plan to ensure that
an appropriate number of spaces are
always available to residents across the
two sites
throughout the construction period so
the impact on the residents of circle
court is limited
so that was just a point of
clarification before i um get into the
presentation
and i'll share the screen and start that
okay i hope that's clear for everybody
yes great thank you okay so we are
looking at an application here for the
erection of a seven story hotel building
with 147 bedrooms this follows the
refusal of a planning application in
september 2020
and that related to the erection of a
nine-story hotel for 197 bedrooms
the site is the 16-storey circle court
tower block as outlined on the slide in
red the slip road to the
m60 junction 9 is located to the west
side of the site
and the motorway and slip road are
positioned at a higher level than the
application site as you can
just about see here on the the aerial
view
the north side of the site is lost
circle and that's the main direction we
round about saving junction 9 and that
linked along to barton road
lost road and parkway there's a couple
of photographs just showing the site
which i'm sure are all aware
of but this is um looking within the
site
um you can see the the hard surfacing
within the site and
and the gyratory in in the to the north
are there
and in this photograph is from
um adjacent to the signal called tile
block
and you can see the wider area of the
site
currently consisting of hard surfacing
and soft landscaping along the boundary
with the number of mature
the trees hotel building will
incorporate a rectangular footprint and
form which will be replicated across
all seven stories of the site the main
pedestrian at
entrance would be on the east side of
the building off
barton road and with a secondary
pedestrian entrance on the west
elevation access from the hotel car park
the vehicular access to the site will be
taken from barton road as per the
previous application
and there'll be 147 car parking spaces
provided
which includes six spaces for electric
charging vehicles and nine accessible
spaces
location has received four letters of
support and a petition with 19
signatures
in support of the proposal along with
five letters of objection
this is compared with 19 letters of
objection to the previous application
the principle of the main town centre
use for a hotel in this location
is considered acceptable with no
sequentially preferable sites being
identified in accordance with the mppf
this is unchanged from the previous
application and there were no reasons
for refusal
relating to the principle of the use so
as i've said we had the previous
application last year and that was
refused by members for three reasons
the detailed reasons are upon us now and
unrelated to size appearance sighting
loss of trees the second accessibility
to sustainable modes of transport and a
shortfall in car parking spaces
and the third around the access
provision and the provision of uh
appropriate visibility displays the
applicants are sought to address these
reasons
for refusal and as significantly amend
the scheme
working with officers in the local
community in terms of the proposals
the next set of slides will show a
comparison between the previously
refused application and the current
proposal
to give members an understanding of the
changes made
so firstly what we see is a reduction in
height
from nine to seven stories and you can
clearly see this
in the in the in the images here you can
see that the previous scheme nine
stories
coming down to seven and part four
stories in the current proposal
what this does is it reduces the number
of bedrooms from 197
in the previous scheme to 147 currently
what you also see in these plans is a
change in appearance
and a breakup in mass a change in the
use of colour of
the materials and and materials used
introduction of the gray and red bricks
and which are considered more reflective
of the character of the area
also a large expanse of of glazing has
been introduced at the ground floor
which is considered to activate the
street frontage onto barton road
and clearly define this same pedestrian
entrance
in addition to this the footprint has
been reduced
uh by approximately 240 square meters
as you can see on the in the site plan
comparison here
the previous scheme and was much larger
when we see the current proposal here
in addition to that the building line
has been significantly set back
from the barton road frontage and
allowing the retention
of these five existing trees on site and
creating a real soft landscape buffer
along that barton road um frontage
now if i just quickly move to the next
slide what this shows us
is the um the setbacks
that have that have come from the
previous to the current scheme
so on the previous scheme we had a
setback of 2.3 meters
at this point adjacent to the access and
3.7 meters here
on on the pinch point to barton road and
in the current scheme adjacent to the
access now we have a 10 meter setback
allowing the retention of these two um
trees and on the the pinch point with
barton road we've got a 5.5 metre
setback
officers are um satisfied that this
really addresses the
the concerns over a cramped form of
development allows these treaties to be
retained
and introduces a an extra degree of soft
landscaping and buffer
in between the road frontages and the
proposed building
i think it's also important if i go back
to the original
um site plan it's important to note the
constraints of this site and the
position of the footprint of the
building
um we have a culvert and a major um
major pipe line running through the site
so the position
and the footprint of the building is is
is is pretty fixed
in in this part of the the site so the
the applicant has had their work cut out
in in trying to accommodate the
development with with those constraints
going back to the comparisons um
the previous application was for 197
um bedrooms with 127 car parking spaces
what we see now in this current
application is a 147 bed hotel
and 147 car parking spaces provided
so they've they've been able to amend
the scheme to provide 100
provision of car parking spaces in
accordance with the maximum standards
and that's our guidance set set off
as previously mentioned additional trees
are retained so
six of the 11 trees on site are now to
be retained
and the previous scheme sought only to
retain one
in addition to that 13 new trees are
proposed to be planted along with other
soft landscaping works
and this is considered to mitigate the
loss of those existing trees and this is
supported
by the council's tree officer the
existing
six trees that remain on site will be
protected during construction
and an updated and strengthened tree
protection condition
is is included within the air
the moving to look at the um changes
around the access and the visibility
displays
the applicants thought to to move this
ex this substation and generator that
they proposed in the previous proposal
and and recite that into a different
part of the site and that really opens
up
and allows um the appropriate visibility
slaves
to be um to be provided and to be
achieved
in addition to that the applicant has
provided an assessment on sustainable
forms of transport available to staff
and customers
within the local area and a framework
travel plan
with a condition requiring a full travel
plan to be submitted
before the occupation of the development
scheme also secures funding towards
improvements to the existing pedestrian
cross
crossing at the circle and to upgrade um
footways within the local area this
proposal this slide and just shows you
the views
from the the m60 and and over the car
park and again you can just see those um
elevational
changes that have been made to to get
the treat to the building
the the reduction in mass particularly
um on this part of the building and the
breakup of the the elevation
through the use of of um contrasting
bricks
so the new building will incorporate a
conventional
angular form and will incorporate
vehicle glazed elements
articulated by the brick frame design
with a variety of brick bonds
and now proposes contrasting gray and
red coloured bricks
recesses across the elevations um
are proposed and these changes are
really considered to reflect the
character of the wider area
the hotel is well designed and it would
be a positive addition to the area
and offices are satisfied that this is
addresses the the design reason for
refusal
improvements to hard and soft
landscaping are also proposed with the
retention of existing trees and new tree
planting throughout the site
these works will greatly improve the
environment of the site and further
addressed
in the prerequisites for refusal
it is considered that significant
amendment have been made to the
development
and they have successfully addressed the
previous reasons for refusal
overall the applicant is con the
application considered acceptable
and in accordance with the development
plan and the mppf and officers therefore
recommend
approval of the application subject to
conditions thank you
thank you those um i believe there's one
speaker um
to this application mr boone
just oh can you can you hear this mr
boob
i can't see andrew booth
as a participant in the chat
i don't know design anybody from
democratic
okay he has got permission to speak the
microphone is on
just not hearing anything coming through
i don't know if there's any way for us
to i can try and admit him as a panelist
try that
i can hear you chair can you hear me
yeah wonderful we can now and
thank you for joining us you've got uh
three minutes to speak to committee and
if you do one overtime i'll just
politely ask that you wrap up your
contribution thank you
thank you chair uh good evening thank
you for the opportunity speaking tonight
i'm andrew booth and i manage london
planning for the create group
which is a local family owned north west
company when we employ just over 100
people
thank you to your officers for the
report it admirably details our
application
so i just wanted to take a couple of
minutes to explain why create offers a
unique proposition
and to outline the improvements that
we've made to our scheme since it was
initially refused in september 2020
as we all know much has changed in the
world since september
and the potential regeneration
investment and employment benefits of
this proposal have never been more
important
as an investor in local communities
we're not just a developer
we're in effect a one-stop shop we
partner with the international hampton
by hilton brand which we'll introduce to
the bower
and as well as being the developer with
a contractor long-term owner and
operator of the hotel
we've therefore got a vested interest in
the long-term success of this project
and its impact on the wider local
community
since the refusal we've we've reflected
on and responded to your observations
and as a consequence we've
engaged in extensive consultation with
members your officers
external consultees and the resident
we've distributed details of our
proposals to over 500 local addresses
and in keeping with the modern covid
world we've held virtual consultation
events
details of the consultations are
included in the offices report but it
was a very
popular platform and we generated
significance interest
consultations have driven our improved
scheme as were your comments
and our in our revised and improved
proposal has resulted in the reduction
from nine stories to seven
and dropping down to four where the
building adjoins lost.court
a 25 reduction in the bedroom numbers to
147
the design that you've seen which
delivers a smalling but a smaller
building
in crete includes recesses reveals and
varied material pallets
to improve the quality in reducing the
impact on the wider area
we've retained an increased number of
existing trees
and delivering a new high quality
landscaping scheme to enhance the
setting of the hotel
we provide significant improvement in
car parking numbers to enjoy that we're
providing one space per bedroom
we've produced an upgraded highway
entrance
which is now supported by your officers
and we've also introduced improvements
in both the quality and quantity of
residence parking
and landscape and public realm benefits
for the residents of the adjoining
circle corps
as a consequence of our improvements the
implication the application before you
is of an exceptionally high standard is
more sympathetic to its surrounding
context
and clearly addresses all of your
previous concerns
it's supported by your officers and has
received a petition and further letters
of support from the public
at a time when growth and investment
will be key in our bounce back from this
pandemic
an approval will help to deliver a 48
million pound
investment protect and create new
construction jobs and apprenticeships
and will deliver over 40 new hospitality
jobs for the local economy
under the circumstances we'd ask you to
support your office's recommendation
and approve these exciting proposals
which we can deliver in very short order
thank you chair thank you mr b and
councillor minis i think you're opening
the discussion
thank you chair um all right the first
thing what a difference
it's it's it's so much better than the
previous one it's
it looks better it's not a big um
quite like you know the same block that
it was before um
i think it's got some nice breaking up
of the heights and
there's one criticism i have
and that this is on i've note that we've
got 147
rooms and 147 car parking spaces what so
one per room which is
which is great and we're going to land
up the way that we
are the the the people are moving is
towards electric car
uh usage six charging spots
really um i would think that with that
number of spaces you need to have at
least thirty
uh you need to look towards the future
the future is
more and more electric cars i'm seeing
them a lot in timperley
and spotting them and my children spot
them all the time
so um a hell of a lot more in the last
year that's clearly the way we're going
i would like that um i have nothing
nothing wrong with the rest of it
um i don't think it's a lot better than
the previous um
application but i would like the number
of ev charging
spots to go up to 30. at least if not
more
that's that's uh my part thank you very
much
thank you councillor council according
thanks chair um yeah i opposed from the
floor the uh the
last application mainly i'm on a
bit on grounds of balkan's uh height uh
because i thought it would dominate the
landscape
as much as anything really plea i think
i
think planning committee can pat itself
on the back
over what it did with that last
application because i think this is far
far better um i don't
as a unlock i think one four seven car
park spaces is far too much for uh
a hotel if i'm honest but it's what we
told them at the last finding
application
and i can't i can't i can't change that
but 147
it takes no account to the fact that
most people
a lot of the uh the clients for this
hotel will be international
uh for matches and for the traffic
center and things like that
a lot will not have cars they'll come on
boxes or whatever
but there you go um i'm in a minority on
that
i really support this and um
i support the jobs and i support the
the the the the work that the the the
that
uh creative done with the uh the
residents and and i think
it's been a really positive exercise all
the way through
so i'm quite happy with it and thank you
very much chair
i'm happy to propose thank you
councillor and councillor tommy
thank you chair uh again broadly in
favor of that i think this is a
wonderful piece of
uh building but i do have one concern
that came from the presentation
where we are going to replenish any uh
circle called residence car parking
i just want to be clear that that's not
coming from the grassed area that's
enclosed around the bottom of circle
court
which is basically the garden of the
residents
if that's fine then i have no no
concerns at all
thank you councillor councillor hartley
thank you yeah i'm also supportive of
this application
so happy to um second council according
to his motion that that we agree the
uh the granting of the application yeah
really pleased to see
that the applicant has uh you know
successfully addressed the the previous
reasons that we that we gave for refusal
and
and has addressed them well um you know
the reduction in the
in the size of the building the
sequential test is satisfied as
it was before um and i think um
i think one of the residents said you
know it's an improvement to the
to the immunity of the area it's better
to look at the modern hotel than to look
at the m60 and
and um i mean i think it's better than
that i think the landscaping is better
increased tree retention and planting is
really welcome
i think the design actually complements
circle court quite well so i think it
looks looks good in in
setting in its setting um
a lot of residents uh a lot more
residents are supportive i know that
there are still
some who object but there are a lot more
supportive comments from from residents
now
so yeah i applaud the developer for
taking on board the
the previous reasons for refusal you
know as counts accordingly said
um it's a much it's a much better scheme
that
um has considerable benefits for the for
the community and and for the local
economy as
as i see it so happy to um to approve
the officer recommendation
chair thank you thank you council of
hunting
yes thank you chairman um obviously as
uh other members of the committee have
stated it's a significant
improvement upon the upon the last
application but then again
that's not very difficult to improve
upon the last application by the looks i
think they were very much chancing their
arm last time just trying to see what
they could get away with more than
anything else and uh
that we've now got a far more realistic
uh proposal
i mean it's yeah the building will fit
in far better than the existing with the
previous one the design is better
although
it's hardly a thing of beauty it's not
like anyone's gonna look at the building
and think um
i think it's attractive it's got very
little architectural merit
it's just hasn't got all the massive
negatives that came with the previous
one but then again chairman i think
that's
very much a part of modern architecture
i think most architects take a vow upon
completion of their training
thou shalt not build anything beautiful
um
with that said chairman uh it's a
functional building
just there to do a functional job i
don't suppose the
architects intended for it to be too too
attractive
it's just somewhere to be able to sleep
when they go into a football match or
visit
the traffic center or whatever else
they're doing so uh there is nothing
really to sustain a
uh refusal on those grounds chairman i'm
more than happy to be voting in favor
thank you chairman
thank you councillor and council of
acting
thank you chair uh i think it is a much
improved
uh development from from the previous
application the developer has addressed
i think all of the
objections to refuse uh the previous
application and i think particularly the
height
that that was a problem i think for a
lot of people
um and um you know the other
the other issues that um that was
objected to
previously i think have actually been
addressed so um the developers did reach
out to the residents and the
consultation
was good and i think um
they did take note of what residents
had actually said and i think that's
quite refreshing
to to some developers
and i i do support this
now and i think it will help to
regenerate the area
um it is a bit of a blight on that
corner
um and you know i go go past it
practically every day and
uh and i think it will improve and and
uh that that that part um
of the where the roundabout is and
everything else and i and i think it
will improve
uh for circle court as well and and
there are shops in in the area a small
row of shops and i think it will help to
regenerate
those as well so all in all i am in
favor of it
okay thank you
councilman councillor jerome do you want
to make your contribution then we'll
come to ms loves as well thank you
i just wanted to make it very quick i
objected mainly on on the trees last
time i think the willow and
the maples that are on the perimeter are
kind of iconic to the site
they're beautiful mature trees and and
they add to the biodiversity and the
beauty of the area
and to bring those down was plain wrong
so i'm really glad the developers have
listened to that
and also i'm in um council accordingly
minority
i probably think there are too many car
parking spaces now but overall i'm
pleased that the developers come back
with a good application thanks chair
thank you councillor i don't want to
sort of repeat what everyone else is
there but i would just say that
i i'm really pleased that this
application has come back to us
uh in the format that has i think it's a
dramatic improvement on
what was previously proposed and
i think the amount of effort that the
applicant has decided to go into
and improving the scheme and in being
able to demonstrate to us that the
scheme has been improved last time i
think we just received a
sort of drawing of a great box plot on
the site and it's clear that much more
efforts come into trying to demonstrate
that this will be a benefit rather
than detract from the site um
so i i'd just like to put on mic of my
thanks to the applicant for
the way that they've gone about and
bringing back the application and the
work that the planning authority has
also done
to try and come up with a better
proposal for the area
and ms loves um i think councilman minis
raised a point about
the number of ebc uh points and then
also council thomas had a query about
some green space on the site if
yes thank you chip yep i can answer both
those points no problem um
in in relation to the electric charging
points
and condition 29 of the um
that's proposed basically sets out that
we would
that will look for details of the
charging point and other passive
infrastructure
and what the applicant has agreed to is
whilst they're going to put
six charging points in they're gonna put
passive infrastructure in
the rest of the site so should the usage
increase
the passive infrastructure is in place
so they can just put the charging points
in when and if the demand comes and so
basically it'll be it's it's
future-proofed in in that respect
that all of the um the infrastructure
will be in place for the the charge
points to be added when they're needed
and that's what condition 29 allows for
in relation to council thomas's point
um so the car parking proposal is it was
a separate application that came in
through
um trafford housing trust and it is
located to the south of um
circle court it's mainly on the hard
surface area to the south
circle corporate does take up a small
portion of the green space
but what i would um set out my
understanding is as
part of these um works and the
introduction of the new car parking
spaces that thtr
including a comprehensive landscaping
scheme um
around and adjacent to the car parking
spaces to mitigate
that that impact and so we weren't too
concerned about that small loss of
of green space when we um granted that
separate permission
hope that answers the questions thank
you
ms lowe's um it has been proposed and
seconded that
the application be approved in line with
office recommendation uh
we'll just give members an opportunity
to indicate anyone who hasn't spoken
wishes to do so
but i think that's probably a relatively
bored agreement there
okay we'll move towards and
as usual i'll just cycle through members
as you appear on my screen and
counsel a minute
thank you very much for that that answer
ms lowe's
um i'll be voting in line with officer
recommendation to grant thank you
thank you and council jermaine i support
officer recommendation to grant thanks
chair thank you council bunting
recommendations grant chairman thank you
councilman stanley
uh in line with officer recommendation
to grant please check thank you
councilman
support recommendations to grant chair
thank you and councillor morgan
as for officer recommendations to grant
chair thank you councillor accordingly
support officer's recommendation chair
thank you councillor dr barclay
i support officer recommendation to
grant thank you
councillor kerry uh grant police
chairman
thank you councillor hartley thank you
chair support officer recommendation
instagram
thank you thank you councillor thomas
oh sorry counselor we can't hear you
sorry chair support officer's
recommendation thank you
and i shall also be voting in line with
officer recommendation
to grant that application is approved i
think
unanimously um just
before we move to any further
item that there has been a query i think
in the chat from legal services about
whether
there should be a change to the running
order i don't know
who's colleague you've seen that
i i have and i think it's a sensible
suggestion chairman
um
so legalistic
so we were going to take next um two
waitrose applications together
but legal have advised that we could
only vote on one of them if we overrun
now that obviously doesn't work very
well if we're reconvening on
monday in terms of reconvening into a
second vote when the discussion has been
on a thursday
um so the next application on the agenda
after that was stratfor
blick hall now um chairman i think we
probably can
cover that in the 20 minutes or so we
have left with a slight overrun would
you
happy to take that one albeit um council
hartley will take the chair of course
yeah i'm happy with that councillor
heartland
um i just asked ms milner if she's
able to present that um
if she was expecting to obviously she
wasn't necessarily expecting to get
there
um yes i i am i'm
excellent in which case it's fine
i'll leave the meeting now then thank
you
right thank you i've muted yes so we'll
go on to the uh
today item on straight for public hall
so um uh
miss miller i think you're going to do
the uh the introduction thank you
i am um i'll just upload
share my presentation
and i've had problems in the past
in sharing my screen so can you just
confirm
when you can if you can see the
presentation
yes i can yes great thank you
so the application before members
relates to stratford public hall
and chester road instructed it's a
variation of condition which seeks very
um conditions on a consent from 2014
which was also varied um at planning
committee
in september 2019 the variation seeks
specifically to look at conditions
four and five relating to the hours of
use and also the hours in which
amplified music can be played
in additional on this application
they're looking also specifically to
be able to open windows and
to to the building to allow for
ventilation
which was briefly prohibited so i'm sure
you
you're familiar with the building but
just to to orientate yourself this is
um looking at a structured proper call
from along chester road
and then um again along dorset street
now as you can see there are residential
properties
and to the side and rear of the
public hall and we're going to look at
sorry i'll just just
stop being there just just because they
so the slideshow isn't
moving on we're still on the first slide
and also
um apologies for interrupting i've seen
a message from
councillor carey to say it lost um sound
and i can't see uh cancer carey's
uh video so i'm just i'll just pause
there just just to see if
counselor carrick can hear us now if he
could perhaps indicate that
hey you're with us counselor carrie i
think you're off mute now but we can't
see
no it looks like he is not able to hear
us
um so i'm just wondering whether we uh
whether we continue without him or
whether we wait
and try and get him to reconnect i don't
know it can
um somebody from government services
just shed an in life but on whether
cancer care is still still part of the
call or whether he's having difficulties
um he's still showing us being in the
meeting i'm not recently getting a
message to say he's
not left is left all i can do
is to actually remove him from the
meeting and that will prompt him to try
and rejoin
the other alternative is is to continue
and if he does rejoin
obviously he's not able to take part in
the in the vault
okay the first option yeah let's let's
try that and then see if he tries to get
back in
and then if not we'll carry on i think
thank you
so i charge you am i to carry on
sorry miss miller no i think if we if we
just wait for a moment we'll just see if
councillor kerry can
can get back in uh and if he can't we'll
carry out that point so yeah you could
just bear with us just for a minute
he's now rejoining rejoining so
right i'll just give him a minute
thank you i think i'm back in now i
don't know what happened then
okay wicking here you know council
carrick did you did you hear any of the
presentation from
miss melanie i'm just wondering no
nothing at all sorry i don't know what's
happened
um okay i think
in view of the time i'm loath to miss
milner start again so i don't
miss miller i think if you carry on with
your presentation from where you were
and uh and councillor kerry i think
you'll have to
sit this one out because you've not
heard all of the presentation we can
perhaps chat up with legal services once
we've uh once we've already started
surely uh
if we're going to if it's going to be a
case of excluding the council from the
decision making we should
restart it given the fact that even if
we go over time once we've begun an item
we can complete it and see
this is the only item we're completing
so it would seem
perhaps unfortunate to remove council
carry from decision making
due to the i.t issue we've only started
a minute or two of the
presentation okay thanks cancer bunting
yeah i'm mindful of mindful time
opposite obviously that we're keeping
members and officers here and
so i know we've started the item let's
ms milner you could if you could start
again i think if we have any
more difficulties then we'll we'll just
need to press on um
we've had members that have lost
connection before and they've had to
sit out the item but i think given we
weren't very far into it if you could
start again miss milner thank you
no not not a problem um
i hope you can all see the screen now
and someone else is sharing for me so
and there should be an image while there
is an image and
of the site so it's released to stratfor
public hall um which is a gray two
listed building
on chester road and um on the corner
also at dorset street there are
residential properties on dorset street
and to the rear
um and the application
proposes to vary conditions on a 2014
permission for the change of use
and which brought in um recall
into a range of uses and business uses
residential
um assembly in leisure and also um to
studio
and there were a number of conditions on
the planning permission which were
varied by the committee in 2019 which
sought to increase the opening hours
and the use of amplified music
the current proposal for members tonight
um seeks to vary conditions four and
five
to further extend those hours and
specifically
over over the weekend and also to
um allow for changes in the management
so windows
um opening so what you will now see
before you
is um conditions four and five have been
your report
and being updated to reflect um
the current proposal now originally um
stretch for public hall the friends of
stratfor people called did
um pose greater um
number of um extended learning hours
occasions
and throughout the year but through with
our environmental health team we are
proposing that
amplified music and be extended for
24 occasions per annum up to
um 11 p.m at night on thursdays fridays
and saturdays
and we've no more than four occasions
per calendar month
um friends are seeking a greater use of
36
um occasions per year but we are
proposing that
at the moment we we still have concerns
about the
impact late opening would have on those
um nearby residents and so what we are
proposing is a
like with the 2019 permission a
rather than a year consent in this state
we're proposing 15 month
um permission to allow for for those
later opening hours now
the reason for that 15-month opening and
rather than the classic year
is because of the coming restrictions
uncovered
and hopefully by june and we will be out
of lockdown
and therefore the protocol can operate
in full and therefore from a full
year and to operate the
2018 permission obviously wasn't fully
implemented
because of the lockdown so we are
proposing a 15-month
temporary consent to allow for those
greater and
opening hours now there have been
objections from local residents as
detailed
within your committee reports there are
concerns about the impact on noise and
disturbance
to luke residents and the management and
the talking
concerns about parking and also people
coming and going to the site
and especially when leaving after late
night events and the impact that would
have
on residents officers have have
worked with um colleagues in
environmental health and the applicant
has been forthcoming on
a number of management um solutions and
um
production of a new noise management
plan and we are classified
that subject to the conditions as
outlined in the report and clarification
on the condition for within the
additional information report
that this temporary consent we propose
will allow
um forensic public hold to operate as
for extended hours but also for us to
monitor and assess the impact that would
have on local residents and therefore
subject to the conditions in your report
we do propose approval thank you
chair thank you miss milner um
could i just ask a question about about
the conditions uh and we can
we can maybe hear from the speakers if
you if you need a bit of time to to look
at it mr miller
i just want to understand that the
conditions that are proposed in terms of
the
the hours so i know i'm just looking at
the additional information report i know
there's been a
suggested change but i think it's sort
of broadly still the same so the
um condition 4b about the amplified
music which says it not be played
outside the areas of tentacle 2200 on
any day
safe for those occasions is
is 100 to 200 right or
because the original position was 10
till 9 wasn't it
so i'm just wondering whether that's
intense that's that
that is intentional yes that was a that
was allowed last time
in the 2019 permission so we're happy
with that
but we're saying want to go later then
we feel that that should be rooted to 24
occasions per annum
and more than four per calendar month
right okay yeah i understand okay we
have a
a speaker um against the application
which is miss
cousil are you with us on the commerce
custom
yes i am can you hear me we can yeah i
can hear you later
um yeah if you if you'd like to speak to
us and we'll
time your contribution to three minutes
and if we get to the end of that i'll
just ask you to wrap up your
comments so yeah if you'd like to speak
to us now
thank you okay thank you counselor um
some of the things that i was going to
say has actually been just been said
and i'm sure you've all read our
objections that we've put in
50 times over um i'm speaking on behalf
of the
residents of dorset street regarding the
change of use that they want
due to noise and light pollution as you
can see from the photographs we're very
small street and we are
extremely close to the actual hall
actually between
seven and 15 meters distance from all of
our properties
and our upper floor our bedrooms on um
the
housing opposite the actual hall there
is only a nine meter difference and this
is where they want to do their amplified
music
opening windows et cetera et cetera as
to our knowledge the
hall has not had any sound proofing work
done to the windows or the walls
on that first floor we know that they've
renovated the floor for holding these
evening events and are asking for the
amplified music to be played on that
floor along with flashing lights etc
now the um all premises we've been told
applying for licenses should demonstrate
that its customers will be able to
be capable of leaving the area without
causing a disruption
to local residents or impacts upon crime
and disorder
now the only area to park for this hall
and for pickup from this venue
especially at the night time is in our
street
it's right outside our homes or it's a
very small car park that they have at
the side of one of the homes
that i'm talking about and leading in
and
exiting onto dorset street so this car
park
even if it's used and not our street
will still be coming out the same way
and being a one-way street all the
direction of the traffic will then be
heading
straight into a residential area we'll
have a lot more air pollution along with
noise pollution etc etc
our walls are not very um thick we can
hear quite a lot of noise
um but it's not a big thing it's not
something that's going to be excessive
and late at night the whole they
recently had
um a school group there and when
children were coming out due to covert
they were taking them out
through a gate onto their road and the
noise was extremely loud all the
residents could hear everything that was
being said
but this absolutely wasn't an issue as
it was young children it only lasted for
15 or 20 minutes
and whilst waiting for the parents for
them to pick them up but from this
experience
we can't imagine what noise tens of
people
leaving the venue very merry probably
and party reception situation late at
night with cars
taxes picking up and what it would be
like for us we think is devastating
whilst residents live on dorset street
there really shouldn't be a night venue
with alcohol served
we have no problem for the daytime early
evening activities
and we would like to have meetings to
discuss this with them but they've never
asked us to
thank you very much for listening
thank you very much mr coastal um we
have um a speaker
uh for the application which is uh kate
mcgeever
uh miss mcgeever are you with us on the
call
hello yeah i'm here can you hear me
great
yes we can hear you loud and clear yeah
you'll you'll also have three minutes so
yeah again if you run up to time i'll
just ask you if you could
wrap up your your comments but yeah if
you'd like to speak to us now
then we'll we'll be listening thanks
okay thanks very much
kate mcgeever here the uh manager at the
hall
so friends of stratfor public hall have
been running the hall since 2015 when
trafford council trusted us with the
freehold of the building
through a community asset transfer since
then we've raised over 1.1 million
pounds in investment and grant funding
which we've invested back into the
building and
into our community activities we have
spent over 150
000 pounds on maintenance and repairs to
the building and an additional 480 000
on the recent renovation of the ballroom
hundreds of community groups charities
and small businesses have hired space at
the hall in the time we've been running
it
and we have supported over 75 small
enterprises through the provision of
space in our artist studios and our
co-working space
when we secured the freehold of the
building our business plan which traffic
council approved set out very clearly
our ambition
to establish stratfor public hall as a
multi-purpose event space which could be
used by
for community activities as well as
cultural events and performances
corporate events and private hire events
like weddings
today we have held over 60 different
events 10 cultural events attended by
thousands of people
ranging from film festivals and cinema
screenings to our annual art exhibition
we have suffered a huge loss of income
over the past 12 months and we
anticipate a total loss of revenue of
close to 100 000 pounds due to
coronavirus
our survival until now is a testament to
our sound financial management
and a fundraising and reserves policy
that has got us this far
but it is now absolutely essential to
our survival as a community business
that we are able to operate in the
evenings
to meet the demand we currently have for
parties and for weddings and for other
late night events
in march 2020 the friends of stretford
public hall responded to a request by
trafford council
to operate a stretford community
response hub within 10 days we'd
organised a team of staff and volunteers
who were delivering frontline services
to those most
affected by the pandemic we delivered
food parcels prescriptions and we ran an
emergency phone line for those most in
need to support
as a result of this we have since been
approached by the council to coordinate
the trafford poverty truth commission
an important project that will support
the council's poverty strategy
we also found out this week that we have
secured 50 000 pounds from the national
lottery
to run a social prescribing pilot for
north trafford
the council has trusted us and continues
to trust us to deliver this important
work
and we are now asking you to also trust
us to manage late night events at the
hall
we have set out very clearly on in our
application how we propose to ensure
that events do not impact on our
neighbours and we are confident in our
ability to deliver this
we are happy with the conditions
proposed by the counts by the planning
officers
to limit late night events to three
nights a week at the hall
and the conditions proposed relating to
the opening windows
however we asked the planning committee
to grant our application
for a permanent change to our planning
permission rather than the proposed and
to not limit the number of events
we can hold over the year thank you
thank you miss mcgaber uh could i maybe
just look for some advice ms miller just
on whether
we're able at this stage to consider
what miss mcgee was
saying as an alternative could we
consider um
granting this as a permanent change
so the the change that the temporary
concern is lions
is the condition and therefore you are
able to change you can
you know you are able as the committee
to recommend a changing committee
sorry a change in the kitchen um i'll
i'll make sure that
the legal team are in agreement with
that but that's my understanding that
you are able to
to vary a condition or add a condition
as you see fit
okay thank you that's helpful um i don't
know if anyone from the
legal team wants to confirm that or come
back uh
later in the discussion
i'll perhaps leave that one and and come
back before we before we go sit up to
the vote we'll see how the debate goes
as to
as to what members views are um
councillor bunting i think you wanted to
speak on this
yes thank you chairman um i can very
much see both sides of the story in
relation to this one i understand
absolutely why the uh why the business
itself wants to
uh amend its uh the times of the so
is it's allowed to operate in this way
uh i understand that it
will be very much a case of expanding
the uh variety of events that they'll be
able to hold
at the at the hall uh and will very much
uh assist them in trying to
steer a new financial keel
i also however understand the arguments
put forward by the
by the residents and their concerns
although i'm
hopeful uh that the the uh that any
impact for muslims will be nowhere near
as severe as they are
they are perhaps fearing but i do
understand their fears in relation to
this
so my uh uh i
i'm reasonably confident that given the
conditioning that we've got
in place it can be made to work however
i am not prepared
to go along with the uh request to grant
for permanent status at this stage i
think it is a wise
and prudent um procedure to go through
to give a temporary period first this is
something we have done uh
various occasions in the past when it
has been felt necessary to test out
uh the um test out the proposals and
make sure that there won't be any
long-term problem
uh this is uh the fans uh opportunity to
demonstrate
uh to all concerned that they can make
this work
and that they can operate uh in this way
without causing
undue impact upon upon the residents
so i am prepared to propose chairman if
i may
that we accept officer recommendation as
is i.e temporary permission and
not the permanent permission this is uh
uh
15 months for the funds to demonstrate
their ability to
manage this situation and uh if all this
goes well i'll look forward to hearing
from them again
for uh maybe a permanent permission
in future thank you chairman
next i think it will be useful actually
of members if members are minded to
to agree with the officer recommendation
to grant with the conditions that are in
place
uh i think well i think it'll be useful
for members to say if they're in favor
of granting the the application whether
it's
on the basis of the conditions proposed
or whether they are willing to consider
permanently granting because
um as councilor bunting is just done and
then we get a census to
uh what we can move forward with so yeah
counselor acting
over to you
cancer outside we can't hear you or i
certainly can't i think you're on mute
i am i am sorry about that um yeah i i
was just saying that
um you know stratfor public hall and all
who
work within it uh do a fantastic
job uh and you know it's a facility
for the community and and um
you know they they do tremendous work
there
um i i'm in favor of uh
grandpa granting uh this
um really
it's whether it is temporary or or
permanent
and it is a difficult one as far as i'm
concerned because
uh you know if they have to come back
next year
and they've done well and everything it
will cost them
more money uh you know to to actually
put an application forward and i think
um
when finances are very tight and you
you're scraping to develop a community
facility in the way that they do
um you know it is very hard on them
so um i definitely
would not want to lose this so whether
it's temp
temporary or permanent um you know
we need to go for warmer suppose but
i'd like to hear what others say
okay thank you councillor at 10 uh
councillor minis i think you're next to
speak
um thank you chair so um
i was having a look at this i think
temporary is the way to go because i
think we've got to be fair to the
residents that live nearby
i understand the committee is a really
wonderful community asset
but i think we've got to be fair to
residents and children who live in those
houses that are nearby
and i'm also not a fan i'm afraid of the
open
uh windows that late at night um
you know 11 o'clock at night we're
talking about um
having windows open um and midnight
in fact um i just think that this is
this is a terrible idea to have windows
open
and uh the the amplified music blaring
out
until 11 o'clock it says thursday friday
and saturday
11 o'clock and get rid of the claws to
to
to close the windows and doors so um i
would actually
like to have an um obviously to keep the
the
limited period of time and i'd actually
ask for the windows and doors to be
closed i'm afraid
okay thank you councilman so i think i
think that's another
alternative that we're uh that we're
able to consider
um so i think the closing the windows
and doors is also part of the conditions
uh councillor morgan i think i've got
you next to speak thank you
uh thank you very much um i'm gonna
agree
completely with what council ministers
just said um i
i'm i mean honestly this is till eleven
o'clock
on a thursday night amplified music
it's a weekday um with windows open
i'm i'm staggered we're actually
proposing this
um you know like i i absolutely
understand council acton's
point about it being an incredible
community asset really really is
but that doesn't mean we need we should
just allow any condition to go through
that just
i i mean maybe i'm misreading the ear to
mean this but i mean
it's a friday's a work day for me and
i'm in bed before
um before 11 o'clock um and there might
be residents who also are so i'm really
quite staggered that we're allowing
a condition to allow i i understand the
restrictions to clover have brought
but it's for impacted lots of businesses
um
i i i don't think just because of
covered we should
inflict a really painful thursday night
um for residents 24 nights of the year
thank you thank you council morgan i
think it's worth
getting some advice from miss miller on
the windows issue i think the condition
is
is um that the windows on dorset street
have to be closed after
seven o'clock at night i think so um but
miss miller probably be able to advise
us a bit more on that
yes yes chair you're correct condition
seven in your report
counselors um that that point about the
noise that
with windows open was fully understood
by ourselves in environmental health and
and we agree that up until seven o'clock
they can have the windows open on dorset
street that's the road you saw with the
residential properties
and then from seven o'clock they shall
be closed also on a sunday
they have to be closed and acoustic
curtains have to be
drawn as well so and from seven o'clock
they will be closed
thank you chair thank you that's really
helpful
uh councillor minister does that address
your concern about the windows issue
just one of you want to let us know
where you stand that does if we have if
we're saying that
the the windows on on that street on
that side the building
and and at the back obviously as well so
anything
around that area are closed um
i don't know whether if you're having
windows open at the front
whether that noise is going to you know
end up traveling i don't know but
um i'm just i just think about my
children going to bed and even
me going to bed quite frankly on a
sunday and on a thursday night you've
got work the next day it's just not
really
it's not fair to inflict it on on people
if the if if that
is um the rule so the condition that we
actually said this is their proposal our
conditions are
stating that actually that they have the
doors and the windows closed
and have the the curtains as milner was
saying they're
closed then i guess that that would be
okay i'm still
for a temporary license not not a
permanent good god no
yeah so that so the conditions are that
they that the windows
uh and doors will be closed on on on the
dorset street for start and the curtains
on a sunday so as i understand it
the other the other windows doors on the
front and uh
the other elevations could still be open
that's that's my understanding
um council morgan does that satisfy you
about the
um the windows yeah
it does it does count absolutely but i
still think
the the conditions that are here which
is temporary license
to see how it operates um i think are
only fair
um because if it does travel then we
need to reassess that when it comes back
to the committee
thank you thank you that's useful um
thanks to dr barclay
thank you chairman i think it's a really
fair and balanced proposal
and i'm definitely for a temporary
license i wouldn't support
a permanent license but i think we've
got to really strike a balance between
the hall remaining safely operational we
know that if we don't open some windows
that we increase the risk of
transmission of covid and
that is absolutely critical and we don't
want the halls become a kind of
transmission hotspot for for the for the
virus so i think
it's perfectly reasonable uh to ask for
the door
the windows and and things to be drawn
on uh
on dorset street but definitely to keep
the other windows on the other side
open that is absolutely crucial we do
want the business to be able to flourish
in a really safe way
so i'm really happy i think the hall
does some really great work it's good to
hear
and all the kind of things that are
coming uh to the hall
and for it to flourish uh but definitely
only support
a temporary uh permission thank you
chair
thank you council dr barclay um council
accordingly
uh thanks chair really difficult one
this i think
the the only thing i can add is
to emphasize there is a town centre
location
that actually stratfor public hall has
been
i i'd go as far as pivot same pivotal
to the regeneration of stratford in some
ways
the takeover by the community of that
public hall
is where stretford started to turn the
corner
so it is it's hugely
important uh to stretford that public
hall
um it is in the town center and that
so i
i i'm not i'm not in favor of
granting temporary uh permissions
where it's done as a compromise
between two i think we've got to decide
this
i don't think it's i think it's so
important that i think we
we ought to do it permanently my
inclination is that we should grant this
permanently
i'm not sure that we've got the right
conditions on
use of days thursdays do worry me
um i think he should be much more
confident
and be more inclined to
restructure the conditions on a
permanent basis
to reserve it just to fridays saturdays
and to a certain extent sundays uh than
i am about giving their temporary
permission
that doesn't work for the public hall in
terms of its long-term
viability needs that certainty going
forward wedding bookings are made long
in advance um i'm not inc
i'm not entirely comfortable with a
temporary
so i would propose
no i can't because i'm not ready with
the condition my problem is that i'm not
satisfied with the conditions as they
stand
so if i was satisfied with the
conditions
i would be saying i think i would
propose it to be permanent
but i'm not there yet so i'm almost
inclined to go for a deferment
which is i hate deferments but
i don't think we're there yet but i i
i suspect i'm going to be voted down and
we will go for a temporary
i think it's the wrong decision i think
the the the the committee is not being
brave enough to go for a permanent
condition
if it goes for that compromise but
i don't think we're there with a
permanent condition that i can accept so
i have been two minds i really am i'm
tall
i i probably would prefer a different
but
as it stands i i probably will vote for
what i think is the wrong thing
in going for the temporary one
okay thank you council accordingly uh
councillor
wentz stanley uh
thank you chair i agree with lots of
what counts accordingly said that the
strength of town hall has been
structurally strep of
probably all has been pivotal in the
regenerative stratford
and if it had been in use
in the the the in the way is
being proposed to be used then i also
would be in favor of granting a
permanent
um a license for the um
for what's proposed however when the
people who live on the adjacent streets
bought their houses the stratfor hall
was not used for those purposes so i
think it's unfair now to say
well actually because of the the pivots
the royal stratfor player stratfor
probably calls plane
and then we should grant the um a
permanent
we should grab this permanently so yes
it's a balance
i have great sympathy with both sides of
this argument which is why i've been um
supporting the granting of the of the
temporary
conditions thank you chair
thank you councilman stanley uh
councillor bunting you wanted to
come back in i think yes thank you just
to
help out council accordingly maybe um
i agree that this is an important um
facility i agree it has been pivotal in
regeneration of the local area which is
why i'm giving it the latitude that i am
giving if it wasn't such a builder
if i hadn't had such an impact i would
be very cautious of giving this at all
the only thing i would point out to
councillor calling me just to
assuage his conscience should i be able
to do so
is it just because you're given 15
months temporary doesn't mean you have
to take
15 months temporary if you were in say
six months time
come back and say look we've nailed it
we have now the perfect set of
conditions we have been working on this
we've come up with a fantastic idea and
this is what we're gonna
put forward as a permanent uh planning
commission at that point
you could do so before the 15 months
temporary was up
and then if planning committee granted
that planning application that would
then if and that was permanent
then you'd be then you'd be on the
winner so if nothing
if they do want to come back slightly
earlier they can do so but this gives
them 15 months to assuage all doubts
from a local resident so in 15 months if
i choose to leave it that long
when they come back with their uh their
ideas
the public will be more than satisfied
with it and you'll have very few
if any objections but they don't have to
go
all the way if they don't want to uh so
in some of your concern regarding
weddings being put forward and
and plans being in place they can come
back with an alter if they need to
change the conditions about to make it
permanent sooner there's nothing to stop
them
thank you councillor bunting um council
accordingly and
you indicated that you were you were
going to propose that
um that would that we grant permanently
but then i think you resolved from that
because you weren't happy with the
conditions i just wanted to check
whether
you do want us you do want to put
forward that motion
um i don't think it passed so i i i
don't see any point in testing that
um i i i am more in favor of
the permanent that um councillor
bunting's helpful
or not so helpful question as always
cancer accordingly
yeah so i i'm not going to propose
permanent okay um so councillor bunting
proposed that we agreed officer
recommendation to grant as per the
conditions
proposed uh i other members spoke in
favor of that but i don't think anyone
seconded that motion is there anyone
willing to second that motion
i'm happy to second chair thank you
councillor win stanley
um in in which case no other motions
propose will move to the vote on on that
motion
uh which which is to agree to ground as
per the
conditions proposed by officers so i
will uh go uh around the room in the
order that i can
see you on my list so uh
so first of all i've got counselor
jerome
i support the recommendation to grant
thanks joe
thank you councillor jerome uh
councillor dr barclay thank you chad i
support the officer recommendation to
grant
thank you councillor dr barclay uh
councillor bunting
all officer recommendations are grant
for the temporary period
thank you councillor uh councillor acton
yes uh support the recommendations to
graham
thank you uh councillor
accordingly i support the recommendation
to grant
thank you um
councillor wynn stanley
uh support the recommendation to grant
thank you chair
thank you councillor i apologize i'm
struggling here because people's name
seems to have moved
around on my list as i've been asking i
can't say jerome have i asked you i
can't remember
you've asked me already i have i thought
i had uh councillor morgan you're next
to my list and i don't think i've asked
you
you you know sir
recommendations thank you councillor
uh councillor minis
support officer's recommendation thank
you
thank you um councillor carry on a
message to say he lost his own again so
i think he
is going to sit this one out
and counselor thomas as well i think
missed part of the
uh discussion uh so i think
that is uh everyone apart from me i'm
also in favor of
agreeing with the officer recommendation
to grant us for those conditions so i
think
that is unanimous i don't think i forgot
anybody please
save i have okay that's
unanimous so that application is
approved as proposed
thank you uh i don't know if councillor
williams is still
with oh yeah he is with us i can see him
on my list cancer williams do you want
to
come back and take over at this point i
know that's the last item we're looking
at tonight
yeah thank you um okay well i think
that we can uh close the meeting as we
don't have any